Hey guys, so I go back home tomorrow to Los Angeles. I've been in New York for quite some time. I've really missed my dog Ricky. I haven't seen him in a while. Sorry. Sorry. And I'm really excited. Sorry.
嘿大家，我明天要回洛杉矶了。我在纽约待了挺长一段时间。我真的很想念我的狗瑞奇。我已经有一阵子没见它了。抱歉。抱歉。我真的很兴奋。抱歉。
Really excited to see him. sorry and I'm really excited sorry does it not sound like I'm crying should it sound like I'm crying more What is that like, peanut butter toast? Rice Krispie treat. So dessert. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. It's 15 minutes shy of 10 a.m. and you're eating dessert. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. It's 15 minutes shy of 10 a.m. and you're eating dessert. Well, it's my breakfast really.
真的很兴奋能见到它。抱歉，我真的很兴奋，抱歉，听起来不像我在哭吗？是不是应该听起来更像我在哭？那是什么，花生酱吐司？脆米饼。所以是甜点。等等，等等，等等，现在才早上9点45分，你就在吃甜点。等等，等等，等等，现在才早上9点45分，你就在吃甜点。嗯，这其实是我的早餐。
Okay, I mean, rest crispies are a breakfast cereal, but when they're baked with marshmallows, I guess it kind of takes away. And chase it with some cow pus. That's what I. That. So walk me through just a little bit. Walk me through this morning,
好吧，我的意思是，脆米饼是早餐麦片，但当它们和棉花糖一起烤的时候，我想这就不算早餐了。再配上一些“牛奶”（cow pus）。这就是我……那个。那么，带我了解一下，带我了解一下今天早上，
because you've been out of town for a minute, and you came home and there was a fresh pan of Rice Krispie Treats. Oh my God. Yeah, there was actually. Did you make it? No, I didn't make it, somebody else made it. Was it a request or did you say,
因为你已经离开城里一会儿了，你回到家，发现有一盘新鲜的脆米饼。天哪。是的，确实有。是你做的吗？不，不是我做的，是别人做的。这是你要求的，还是你说，
hey, when I get home I want a full pan of Rice Krispie Treats ready to go? But it was there. Was it a request or did you say, hey, when I get home I want a full pan of Rice Krispies treats ready to go? No, there is a person that I know that knows what I like. When you say no, do you mean to say paid? Maybe just a little bit. Is this a good friend who just does it out of the goodness of their heart?
嘿，我回家时想要一整盘做好的脆米饼？但它就在那儿。这是你要求的，还是你说，嘿，我回家时想要一整盘做好的脆米饼？不，我认识一个人，他知道我喜欢什么。当你说是的时候，你是想说付钱了吗？也许有一点吧。这是一个出于好心才这么做的好朋友吗？
Do you doctor up the Rice Krispies? Some people like to drop M&Ms in there. Oh, M&M's are great. No, this is done regular. It's like breakfast though. It's cereal. Except for the marshmallows. Will mentioned a really good point. There's no difference between this and this,
你会给脆米饼加点料吗？有些人喜欢往里面加M&M豆。哦，M&M豆很棒。不，这个是原味的。不过就像早餐一样。它是麦片。除了棉花糖。威尔提到了一个很好的点。这和这个没什么区别，
like this and the milk. Except for the melted down marshmallows into a glue situation. Yeah, a little bit. All right. Yeah. Well, we got through that. Will, a little bit. All right. Yeah. Well, we got through that. Should we start the recast process?
就像这个和牛奶。除了融化的棉花糖变成了一种胶水状的东西。是的，有一点。好吧。是的。嗯，我们聊完了。威尔，有一点。好吧。是的。嗯，我们聊完了。我们应该开始重录流程了吗？
I don't know how much longer we're going to have Sean with us, you know? What a wonderful ride home we had together, what wonderful time spent we had in New York together. We did have a nice time in New York. We got to see our friend Robert's play, which was amazing. Yeah, McNeil.
我不知道肖恩还能和我们待多久，你知道吗？我们一起回家的旅程多棒啊，我们在纽约一起度过的时光多美好啊。我们在纽约确实度过了一段美好的时光。我们去看了我们朋友罗伯特的戏，太棒了。是的，麦克尼尔。
It's called McNeil, go see it at Lincoln Center. Yeah, it's really good. Robert was so good, Robert Downey was so good in that play. Yeah. How cool was that to go there and see him do that, just excel and be... It was a lot of work, it was very admirable to see. Oh, anything on stage is just nuts.
那部戏叫《麦克尼尔》，去林肯中心看吧。是的，真的很好。罗伯特太棒了，罗伯特·唐尼在那部戏里演得太好了。是的。能去那里看他表演，看他大放异彩，真是太酷了……那需要付出很多努力，看到这些非常令人钦佩。哦，舞台上的任何表演都很疯狂。
Sean, you should try going on stage somewhere. You'd be showing people what you can do. I think you'd be. I'll eat some Rice Krispies if I go home spiced. If you're calling last long enough to book some sort of a Broadway gig. Has anybody ever done a Broadway show wearing a diaper? Do you know?
肖恩，你应该试着去某个地方登台表演。你会向人们展示你能做什么。我想你会的。如果我回家时加点料，我会吃些脆米饼。如果你能坚持足够长的时间去预订某种百老汇演出的话。有人穿过尿布演过百老汇吗？你知道吗？
Hey, Sean, you know, I will say, one of the things I enjoyed about going that night was before and afterwards, with a very sort of New York theater crowd, seeing how many people you know in the community. Yeah, it was really fun. Oh, thanks, man. Yeah, it was, it's good to see all those people. It's just like, you know, just like this coast,
嘿，肖恩，你知道，我会说，那天晚上我喜欢的一件事是演出前后，和一群非常纽约的戏剧观众在一起，看到你在社区里认识了多少人。是的，真的很有趣。哦，谢谢，伙计。是的，确实，看到所有人真好。就像，你知道，就像这个海岸，
everybody knows everybody, you know. I really want so badly to do that, to do something on stage. Will, you- Well, you better be careful, because somebody's going to hear that. No, I'm screaming it. I just don't know when the time would be,
每个人都认识每个人，你知道的。我真的很想那样做，在舞台上做点什么。威尔，你——嗯，你最好小心点，因为有人会听到的。不，我在大声喊出来。我只是不知道什么时候才是，
the best time, the right time, with the kids, and the other stuff that I'm working on. It's a full, I almost, as you know, I almost pulled the trigger this fall to do something. But you've done a bunch in the past, right? Yeah, but not on Broadway. But off Broadway. But some New York theater, yeah.
最好的时间，合适的时间，考虑到孩子们，还有我正在做的其他事情。这是一个完整的，正如你所知，我今年秋天差点就下定决心去做点什么了。但你过去做过很多次，对吧？是的，但不是在百老汇。是外百老汇。但有一些纽约戏剧，是的。
Yeah, but I mean, goddamn, is it a million goddamn years ago? But I really was like, you know what, Sean, I was inspired by you and how great you were. Oh, you're very sweet. And it's true, and I thought, God, that really looks like a lot of fun, and seeing Robert do it looks like a lot of fun, but I. It's you have no life.
是的，但我的意思是，该死，那是一百万年前的事了吗？但我真的觉得，你知道吗，肖恩，我被你和你表现得有多棒所激励。哦，你真贴心。这是真的，我想，天哪，那看起来真的很有趣，看到罗伯特做那件事看起来也很有趣，但我。你没有生活。
You literally go from the apartment to your theater, to the theater to the apartment. But that's part of the thing that appeals to me too, is like, you know, New York City's one of my favorite places in the whole world, I've always wanted to live there, but I worry that if I just picked up and moved there, I would be like, well, okay, what do I do all day? Because as an actor or a director or whatever,
你简直是从公寓到剧院，再从剧院到公寓。但这也是吸引我的地方，就是，你知道，纽约市是我全世界最喜欢的地方之一，我一直想住在那里，但我担心如果我搬到那里，我会想，好吧，我整天做什么呢？因为作为一名演员或导演或任何职业，
before you're working, you're not doing anything. And doing a play would give me rehearsals all day, and then once the rehearsals are done, now I've got something to do at night, and then filling a day is, you know, rest. And I think a lot of the day, Sean, it feels like a lot of the day, and correct me if I'm wrong, is taking care of your health.
在你工作之前，你什么都不做。演一部戏会让我整天都有排练，然后一旦排练结束，晚上我就有事可做了，然后填满一天就是，你知道，休息。而且我认为这一天的大部分时间，肖恩，感觉这一天的大部分时间，如果我说错了请纠正我，都是在照顾你的健康。
Yeah, it's PT, physical therapy, because you're like, what do you mean, I got it? But it's the repetitive motions, day after day, every single day of like, Repetitive motions. Pizza, off the plate, into mouth. Pizza, off the plate, into mouth. Rice crisper.
是的，是物理治疗，因为你会想，你是什么意思，我得到了它？但这是重复性的动作，日复一日，每一天，就像，重复性的动作。披萨，从盘子里拿出来，放进嘴里。披萨，从盘子里拿出来，放进嘴里。脆米饼。
Off the plate, into mouth. But in the play, in Robert's play into mouth, off the plate into mouth. Rice crisper. Off the plate into mouth. But in the play, in Robert's play, if you remember there's this one moment where the guy playing his son pushes him on the couch. And the first thing I thought of was, oh my God, his leg must be killing him because his leg hits the arm of the couch and then he falls on the couch.
从盘子里拿出来，放进嘴里。但在戏里，在罗伯特的戏里，放进嘴里，从盘子里拿出来放进嘴里。脆米饼。从盘子里拿出来放进嘴里。但在戏里，在罗伯特的戏里，如果你记得有这样一个时刻，演他儿子的那个人把他推到沙发上。我首先想到的是，天哪，他的腿一定疼死了，因为他的腿撞到了沙发的扶手，然后他摔在了沙发上。
Falling on the couch isn't horrible because you get cushion. But when his leg hits the couch, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, twice on Thursday, Friday, and then twice falls on the couch. Falling on the couch isn't horrible because you get cushioned, but when his leg hits the couch, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, twice on Thursday, Friday, and then twice on Saturday, you have to go get that PT, a physical therapy, like figure out how to, or wear like a... You think he's wearing a pad?
摔在沙发上并不糟糕，因为有垫子。但当他的腿撞到沙发时，周一、周二、周三，周四两次，周五，然后周六两次摔在沙发上。摔在沙发上并不糟糕，因为有缓冲，但当他的腿撞到沙发时，周一、周二、周三，周四两次，周五，然后周六两次，你必须去做物理治疗，想办法，或者戴上一个……你觉得他戴了护垫吗？
Pad or something, yeah. The people with incredibly admirable, true labor situations, they want to come through the microphone and blow your brains out. Oh yeah. I know. true labor situations in the world. They want to come through the microphone and blow your brains out. Oh, is he banging his leg on a couch once a night? They're like, these fucking clowns. Is he building buildings or fighting wars?
护垫之类的，是的。那些处于极其令人钦佩的真实劳动环境中的人，他们想穿过麦克风把你的脑袋炸掉。哦，是的。我知道。世界上真实的劳动环境。他们想穿过麦克风把你的脑袋炸掉。哦，他是一晚上撞一次腿吗？他们会说，这些该死的小丑。他是在盖楼还是在打仗？
No, I know, totally, I get it. I'm just in our little privileged world. How many of our listeners are operating a jackhammer while they're listening to us, do you think? By the way, I got home from New York to our house here in LA and I forgot that I stopped using a sheet under the big- The comforter? Yeah, under the comforter.
不，我知道，完全明白，我懂。我只是在我们这个特权小世界里。你觉得我们的听众中有多少人在听我们节目时正在操作手提钻？顺便说一下，我从纽约回到我们在洛杉矶的家，我忘了我不再在大被子下面用床单了——那个羽绒被？是的，在羽绒被下面。
And it's great. The duvet? Yeah, so have you guys, do you guys still sleep with a sheet and then a duvet? No, just the duvet. Yeah, you can't do it because it gets in your legs and you get tangled. I go one better, I go one better.
这很棒。羽绒被？是的，所以你们，你们还在用床单然后盖羽绒被吗？不，只用羽绒被。是的，你不能那样做，因为它会缠住你的腿，你会纠结在一起。我更进一步，我更进一步。
Amanda and I have two separate duvets so that there's no midnight, mid-night fighting over the duvet. Oh, that's a good idea. I can cocoon myself, she can cocoon her. Midnight, mid-night fighting over the duvet. I can cocoon myself, she can cocoon her. You can knock on the door and enter her cocoon if it's a special night. That's how the kids are made, when you enter her cocoon.
阿曼达和我有两个单独的羽绒被，这样就不会在半夜为了抢被子而打架。哦，这是个好主意。我可以把自己裹起来，她也可以裹住她自己。半夜为了抢被子而打架。我可以把自己裹起来，她也可以裹住她自己。如果是一个特别的夜晚，你可以敲门进入她的茧。孩子们就是这样造出来的，当你进入她的茧时。
You ask to enter her cocoon. Knock, knock, cocoon enter. You're very traditional that way. Permission to board, well it's permission to board, is the language she prefers, and then flutter in like a butterfly. Permission to board, I'm sorry, you're in the back tonight.
你请求进入她的茧。敲敲门，茧进入。你在这方面很传统。请求登船，嗯，这是她喜欢的语言，请求登船，然后像蝴蝶一样飞进去。请求登船，抱歉，你今晚在后面。
Wow. Uh-huh. Wow. That's really funny. I stole that trick from you, JB, with the separate duvets, and very helpful. Works, right?
哇。嗯哼。哇。那真的很有趣。我从你那里偷学了那招，JB，用单独的羽绒被，非常有帮助。管用，对吧？
Yeah. Oh God, it's so good. But don't you agree that the sheet, a sheet you get tangled up in at night. It's nonsense, I don works, right? Yeah. Oh God, it's so good. But don't you agree that the sheet, a sheet you get tangled up in at night. That's nonsense. I don't get it. Yeah. I don't get it.
是的。哦天哪，太棒了。但你不觉得床单，晚上你会缠在床单里吗？这简直是胡扯，我不管用，对吧？是的。哦天哪，太棒了。但你不觉得床单，晚上你会缠在床单里吗？那是胡扯。我不明白。是的。我不明白。
Who would look at that? All right, here we go. All right, it's not the classiest transition into our classy guest, but it's going to have to do. Gang, what is an impressive number of Grammys to win? Okay. Sean, you go first. Any more than one. Will?
谁会看那个？好了，我们开始吧。好了，这不是我们优雅嘉宾最优雅的过渡，但只能这样了。伙计们，赢得多少格莱美奖才算令人印象深刻？好吧。肖恩，你先来。超过一个就行。威尔？
Yeah, I would say one is very impressive. One is amazing, but two, like more than one. Right, it wasn't a fluke. No, no, exactly. Yeah, correct. Exactly. Well, three would definitely, would definitely fall for it.
是的，我会说一个就非常令人印象深刻。一个就很棒了，但两个，比如超过一个。对，那不是侥幸。不，不，完全正确。是的，没错。完全正确。嗯，三个绝对，绝对会让人信服。
I feel like you're gonna go higher. I feel like you're gonna go higher. What about, what would eight do for you? That would be impressive. That's a bounty. Right, if you doubled that, it would be outrageous, right? So that's what she's gone and done. She's won 16 Grammy awards. What?
我觉得你会说更高的数字。我觉得你会说更高的数字。那八个呢？那会令人印象深刻。那是一笔奖金。对，如果你把那个翻倍，那会很离谱，对吧？所以这就是她所做的。她赢得了16项格莱美奖。什么？
She's also a bestselling author, New York Times list. She's a producer of film and television and Broadway. She's an entrepreneur, a force in the world of activism, she has sold over 65 million records and has had over 5 billion streams. We can talk about her music, her skincare line, her art collection, or her new Broadway hit which has received 13 Tony nominations. I've seen it, it's incredible. Please welcome the one and only Alicia Keys. Oh my God! Hey!
她还是一位畅销书作家，《纽约时报》榜单。她是电影、电视和百老汇的制片人。她是一位企业家，是行动主义领域的一股力量，她卖出了超过6500万张唱片，流媒体播放量超过50亿次。我们可以谈谈她的音乐、她的护肤系列、她的艺术收藏，或者她那部获得13项托尼奖提名的百老汇新剧。我看过，太不可思议了。请欢迎独一无二的艾丽西亚·凯斯。天哪！嘿！
Hi! That was good vibes! This is amazing! It's a very impressive intro. This is amazing! I didn't embellish any of it. Wow! Hi!
嗨！那感觉真好！这太棒了！这是一个非常令人印象深刻的介绍。这太棒了！我没有夸大任何一点。哇！嗨！
Oh my God, it's so nice to meet you. I'm so happy to see you. Jason texted me or emailed me a couple months ago, or I don't know, three or four months ago, he's like, you're the Broadway king or queen. No, I think I said queen. What? Tell me what show to see, and I told him to see your show. Yes, you told him to see Hell's Kitchen?
天哪，很高兴见到你。我很高兴见到你。杰森几个月前给我发了短信或邮件，或者我不知道，三四个月前，他说，你是百老汇的女王。不，我想我说的是女王。什么？告诉我该看什么戏，我告诉他去看你的戏。是的，你告诉他去看《地狱厨房》？
Oh my God, was it good? My goodness. I went with my 17-year-old daughter and we lost our mind. That's the vibe right there. So damn good. Thank God. Exciting. Remind me, I apologize, I should know this.
天哪，好看吗？天哪。我和我17岁的女儿一起去了，我们都惊呆了。那正是那种氛围。太棒了。谢天谢地。令人兴奋。提醒我一下，我很抱歉，我应该知道这个。
The actor that plays you or the version of you, she's just stunning. She's amazing. Her name is Malia Joy Moon. She's just turned 22. This is her very first kind of foray into this world, and she's the protagonist of Hell's Kitchen named Ali. So it's awesome. What is that like?
演你或者演你那个版本的演员，她简直太惊艳了。她太棒了。她的名字叫马利亚·乔伊·穆恩。她刚满22岁。这是她第一次涉足这个世界，她是《地狱厨房》的主角，名叫阿里。所以这太棒了。那是什么感觉？
I mean, the most obvious dumb answer opener, I mean dumb question, sorry, is what is that like to have gone through that process to go, wow, this phenomenal talent is singing my songs and playing a version of me-ish, kind of, but what was that like? That must be crazy. Right, so Hell's Kitchen is definitely, it's not autobiographical,
我的意思是，最明显愚蠢的开场白，我的意思是愚蠢的问题，抱歉，那是什么感觉，经历了那个过程，去想，哇，这个非凡的天才在唱我的歌，演一个某种程度上的我——有点像，但那是什么感觉？那一定很疯狂。对，所以《地狱厨房》绝对不是自传，
but it is based on my experiences growing up in New York. And so finding that power, that girl, that young woman who's on the precipice of kind of finding who she is and rebelling against all the people that want to confine her and keep her safe in a box and all those things. And especially based in New York in the 90s, it definitely required a certain energy.
但它是基于我在纽约成长的经历。所以找到那种力量，那个女孩，那个正处于发现自我边缘的年轻女性，反抗所有那些想要限制她、把她关在盒子里的人，以及所有那些事情。特别是在90年代的纽约，它确实需要某种能量。
And that was actually really tricky to find. Because you know, you can't act certain things. You know? Yeah, she did have like this intangible sort of swagger and comfort in her skin and this presence that was just magnetic from the very start. You know, and she just took you the whole way through it. As did the rest of the cast.
而那实际上很难找到。因为你知道，你不能演某些东西。你知道吗？是的，她确实有一种无形的自信和自在，以及从一开始就具有磁性的存在感。你知道，她带你走完了全程。剧组的其他成员也是如此。
It was. Yeah, it's gonna be hard to find that person. I mean, yeah. You know, it definitely, you know, we workshopped, we developed this piece for 13 years, so. Wow, my God. It definitely took quite a long time, but I think that the coolest part is really,
是的。是的，找到那个人会很难。我的意思是，是的。你知道，我们确实，我们研讨、开发这部作品花了13年，所以。哇，天哪。这确实花了不少时间，但我认为最酷的部分真的是，
you know, when you do find those spirits and that energy. Same with the mom who plays Jersey Shoshana, Bean, who is just like, she's exploding your brain. You can't even, so it's thrilling. I would imagine that maybe at the beginning, 13 years ago, you might humbly say that you're not young enough to play that part right now, but I would disagree with you, but certainly 13 years ago,
你知道，当你真的找到那些灵魂和那种能量时。演妈妈的乔珊娜·比恩也是，她简直让你大脑爆炸。你甚至无法想象，所以这太令人激动了。我想也许在开始的时候，13年前，你可能会谦虚地说你现在不够年轻去演那个角色，但我不同意你的看法，但肯定13年前，
it must have been a conversation at some point that you might play that part, maybe? You know, I really, I didn't plan to play the part. I mean, maybe there was conversations at times, or maybe it would be like we could do some fun, limited moment of it or something. But I've realized that it really is so, it's so cool to be able to just come to the theater,
在某个时候一定有过关于你可能会演那个角色的对话，也许？你知道，我真的，我没打算演那个角色。我的意思是，也许有时有过对话，或者也许我们可以做一些有趣的、有限的时刻之类的。但我意识到，能够来到剧院，
watch the show, you know what I mean? Like not have to deliver all the things. It's a lot less work to watch it than to be in it. Am I remembering correctly that you did perform with them at the Tonys? I did, I did. You did, yeah, yeah. I did, you know, just harvest the New York energy for the moment.
看演出，你知道我的意思吗？就像不必交付所有那些东西。看演出比参与演出要轻松得多。我没记错的话，你在托尼奖上和他们一起表演了？我做了，我做了。你做了，是的，是的。我做了，你知道，只是为了那一刻收获纽约的能量。
That must have been exciting to like, to be on stage with them and do some of that stuff, yeah. And that was my first Tonys ever, you know, so that was a unique experience, super cool. That's great. Have you done a musical or a play or anything as an actor? As an actor, I have not. As a producer, I did a play called Stick Fly,
那一定很令人兴奋，就像，和他们一起在舞台上做那些事情，是的。那是我第一次参加托尼奖，所以那是一次独特的经历，超级酷。那太棒了。你作为演员演过音乐剧或戏剧吗？作为演员，我没有。作为制片人，我做过一部叫《Stick Fly》的戏，
which was one of the most written by Lydia Diamond. It was one of the most unique, incredible pieces about a family, a black family in Martha's Vineyard, and it was stunning. It was really, really unique. That was one of the first ones, but this would be my first musical. Do you have any desire,
这是由莉迪亚·戴蒙德写的。这是关于一个家庭，一个玛莎葡萄园的黑人家庭，最独特、最不可思议的作品之一，它太惊艳了。它真的、真的很独特。那是第一批作品之一，但这将是我的第一部音乐剧。你有任何渴望吗，
like what we were talking about earlier, to go on stage and do a play, either as an actor or a dancer, singer, in a musical? You know, I have to say that I have the utmost respect for these artists. I think that artists and musicals are by far the most talented. You have to be a triple threat at all times.
就像我们之前谈到的，去舞台上演一部戏，无论是作为演员还是舞者、歌手，在音乐剧中？你知道，我必须说，我对这些艺术家怀有最大的敬意。我认为音乐剧中的艺术家是迄今为止最有才华的。你必须时刻成为全能型人才。
You have to deliver every single part of it. I don't know if I would have that stamina and that capacity to be honest. You seem kind of limited in what you can do in this life. No, no. Good for you seem kind of limited in what you can do in this life. No, no. Good for you for knowing your ceiling. No, but I was just talking about, we were talking about it before you came on, Alicia,
你必须交付其中的每一个部分。老实说，我不知道我是否有那种耐力和能力。你在这个生活中能做的事情似乎有点有限。不，不。为你感到高兴，你在这个生活中能做的事情似乎有点有限。不，不。为你感到高兴，因为你知道自己的上限。不，但我只是在说，我们在你来之前谈过，艾丽西亚，
that the stamina of it, you hit it, which is the stamina of it, not just going and being amazing, performing and singing and doing all that, but doing it night after night, it's mind blowing. Yeah, but you do it, Alicia, when you go on tour. You do it on tour. Yeah, it's kind of like a, you know.
那种耐力，你击中了要点，也就是那种耐力，不仅仅是去表现得惊人，表演、唱歌、做所有那些事情，而是夜复一夜地做，这太令人震惊了。是的，但你做到了，艾丽西亚，当你巡演的时候。你在巡演时做到了。是的，这有点像，你知道。
It's totally like tour, for sure, and tour is hard. Tour is not eight nights a week, eight shows a week. This is true. Or nine shows a week, it's not. You know, I'm probably doing five shows a week, maximum. Yeah, but still. But I definitely, and I think that's what, as the lead producer of the show,
这完全就像巡演，当然，巡演很辛苦。巡演不是一周八晚，一周八场演出。这是真的。或者一周九场演出，不是。你知道，我可能一周做五场演出，最多。是的，但仍然。但我绝对，我认为这就是，作为该剧的首席制片人，
and also just the, I think me having that experience is definitely different for them because they know that I do understand the rigor and the power and the energy it takes to harness to bring that together. So they definitely feel understood by me, and I totally understand it. But it's incredible watching them work.
而且也只是，我认为我有那种经历对他们来说绝对不同，因为他们知道我确实理解那种严谨、力量和能量，需要汇集起来才能实现它。所以他们绝对感到被我理解，我完全理解它。但看着他们工作真是不可思议。
And so yes, could I do it? Yes, I could do it, but I actually haven't, I haven't done it yet. Right, well maybe you and I will do a two-hander. I'll find something we can work together. This is great. We're making news. Yeah, we're making news today.
所以是的，我能做到吗？是的，我能做到，但我实际上还没有，我还没做过。对，好吧，也许你和我可以做一个双人戏。我会找到我们可以一起合作的东西。这太棒了。我们正在制造新闻。是的，我们今天正在制造新闻。
We're going to do it together. All right, so Alicia, so now, speaking of Hell's Kitchen, is the part, you say it's loosely based on your upbringing or inspired by, tell me about the early part of that story with the influence of the mentor and the piano playing.
我们要一起做。好了，艾丽西亚，那么现在，说到《地狱厨房》，这个角色，你说它是松散地基于你的成长经历或受其启发，告诉我那个故事的早期部分，关于导师的影响和钢琴演奏。
How did you find the piano? Is that true to story there? Take me through that start of the musical sort of fascination for you. Music fascination, sorry. Okay, just music fascination for me, separate of the musical. Correct, correct, yeah.
你是怎么发现钢琴的？那个故事是真的吗？带我了解一下音乐剧对你那种迷恋的开始。音乐迷恋，抱歉。好吧，只是我对音乐的迷恋，与音乐剧分开。正确，正确，是的。
Okay. How'd you start playing music? Right, how did I start? Thank you for a direct question. Yeah, I do tend to flower. How'd you do music first? Yeah, so. Well, I guess I started playing piano around six or seven years old.
好吧。你是怎么开始玩音乐的？对，我是怎么开始的？谢谢你的直接提问。是的，我确实倾向于发散。你是怎么先做音乐的？是的，所以。嗯，我想我大概六七岁的时候开始弹钢琴。
Were people playing piano at home? Were your mom and dad super into it? They weren't. I was raised by my mother. She was definitely an artist, but not necessarily a musician. My grandmother, her mother, did play piano, so I do remember when we would, she would come watch me when my mother would have to go out of town for work or whatever, and she would play the piano, or if we visited her, and they grew up in Toledo, Ohio, so if we went to Ohio to visit grandma,
家里有人弹钢琴吗？你妈妈和爸爸非常喜欢吗？他们没有。我是由我母亲抚养长大的。她绝对是一位艺术家，但不一定是音乐家。我的祖母，她的母亲，确实弹钢琴，所以我确实记得当我们，当我的母亲不得不出城工作或什么的，她会来看我，她会弹钢琴，或者如果我们拜访她，他们是在俄亥俄州托莱多长大的，所以如果我们去俄亥俄州看望祖母，
she definitely would play piano. So she was a person who played piano in my life, but the obsession with piano felt kind of natural. I was drawn to it in this very natural way. I would pass the Steinway store on 57th Street, I would just nose to the window. Really? Did you study?
她绝对会弹钢琴。所以她是生活中弹钢琴的人，但对钢琴的痴迷感觉很自然。我以一种非常自然的方式被它吸引。我会经过57街的施坦威商店，我就会把鼻子贴在窗户上。真的吗？你学过吗？
I love that story too, and I don't even play piano, and I've always been fascinated with that story. Yeah, I love it too. But did you sit down, so you started taking lessons, how long did you say you were? Like you were little? Six, seven, six or seven. So did you sit down and were you like,
我也喜欢那个故事，我甚至不弹钢琴，我一直对那个故事很着迷。是的，我也喜欢。但你坐下来，所以你开始上课，你说你多大？就像你很小的时候？六、七岁，六或七岁。所以你坐下来，你是那种，
yeah, I get this, they're like, this is this, and you're like, yeah, I kind of got this. It was definitely not as, learning an instrument is not natural. It's difficult, you know? It's not, and especially as a young person and you're kind of trying to find your focus and how do you put it all together
是的，我懂了，他们说，这是这个，然后你说，是的，我有点懂了。这绝对不像，学习乐器并不自然。这很难，你知道吗？这不是，尤其是作为一个年轻人，你有点试图找到你的焦点，你如何把这一切放在一起，
and the ambidextrous, using both hands at the same time, two different things. I remember when I first started playing Bach, who's one of my favorite composers, Bach, I just, I love the way the right hand will take it and then the left hand will grab it, but your left hand, I'm righty, so my left hand is not as strong like the right hand will take it and then the left hand will grab it. But your left hand, I'm righty, so my left hand is not as strong as my right hand.
以及双手同时做两件不同的事情，左右手互搏。我记得我刚开始弹巴赫的时候，他是我最喜欢的作曲家之一，巴赫，我只是，我喜欢右手拿住它，然后左手抓住它的方式，但你的左手，我是右撇子，所以我的左手没有右手那么强。
So the practice that it would take to kind of be able to find the fluidity was really, really hard. So I definitely didn't remember being just like, oh poof, I can play anything anytime. Right, right. But how about the Bach like impromptus and the fugues where like you're saying, like you have to, all cylinders have to be firing with the Bach, like impromptus and the fugues, where, like you're saying, like, you have to, all cylinders have to be firing with the left,
所以为了找到那种流畅感所需要的练习真的、真的很难。所以我绝对不记得当时只是，哦砰，我可以随时弹任何东西。对，对。但巴赫的即兴曲和赋格曲呢，就像你说的，你必须，所有气缸都必须在巴赫的即兴曲和赋格曲中点火，就像你说的，你必须，所有气缸都必须在左手点火，
but the right is trained, it's easier to play the right, because the right always plays the melody, and the left is the foundation, the base. So there's very few composers that write as intricately as Bach for the left hand. So it's kind of a screws with your mind. That's why I look at a drummer, and I'm like, okay, I thought playing piano was hard. Drummer, you gotta have all limbs going all the time.
但右手是训练有素的，弹右手更容易，因为右手总是弹旋律，左手是基础，是低音。所以很少有作曲家像巴赫那样为左手写得如此复杂。所以这有点搞乱你的大脑。这就是为什么我看鼓手时，我会想，好吧，我以为弹钢琴很难。鼓手，你必须一直让所有肢体都在动。
Like I don't understand that. And independent of one another. There's a drummer, I don't want to just sidebar. There's this drummer, I swear to God, he's a Spanish drummer and his name is like Estapio or something, he's made his name for himself. He's become quite big on Instagram. This guy. Oh, I know this guy.
就像我不明白那个。而且彼此独立。有一个鼓手，我不想只是侧边栏。有一个鼓手，我向上帝发誓，他是一个西班牙鼓手，他的名字叫埃斯塔皮奥之类的，他为自己赢得了名声。他在Instagram上变得相当大。这个家伙。哦，我知道这个人。
Do you know that guy? Yes, yes. He's the most incredible drummer. Alicia, you can't believe this guy, what he can do. It's unbelievable. Send me one of those, because I love drumming. Oh, I will. I always wanted to be a drummer.
你认识那个人吗？是的，是的。他是最不可思议的鼓手。艾丽西亚，你不能相信这个家伙，他能做什么。这令人难以置信。给我发一个，因为我喜欢打鼓。哦，我会的。我一直想成为一名鼓手。
And there are people out there who have Instagram accounts that are almost based solely on watching him play on his Instagram account. Right, right. And then they just spent, they're drummers who are going like, what the hell is he gonna do? How do you do this and how do you do this?
而且外面有人有Instagram账户，几乎完全基于看他在他的Instagram账户上演奏。对，对。然后他们只是花时间，他们是鼓手，他们会说，他到底要干什么？你怎么做这个，你怎么做那个？
And he's like, no, it's really easy everybody. And he does this and then all of a sudden the left leg, and then he's got like a triple bass pedal sometimes going at the same time. Like it's not easy. But so you learn, so you're learning that stuff, like you're, and then, but there's a moment where,
然后他说，不，这真的很容易，大家。然后他做这个，然后突然左腿，然后他有时同时有一个三倍低音踏板。就像这不容易。但所以你学习，所以你在学习那些东西，就像你，然后，但有一个时刻，
where what, it just like, it just hits you, like how would you think? When did the crossover from classical, like when we were kids, we all kind of took those classical piano lessons. Right, that's true. I stayed on that path for many, many years, and you went, wait a minute, what's this?
哪里什么，它只是击中了你，就像你会怎么想？什么时候从古典音乐跨越过来，就像我们小时候，我们都参加了那些古典钢琴课。对，那是真的。我在那条路上坚持了很多年，然后你去了，等一下，这是什么？
This isn't classical, this is much cooler. I think that, well, at first I started to really discover, I discovered jazz and like unique, I really discovered stride piano, and that was actually really cool for me. Scott Joplin. What's that? Stride.
这不是古典音乐，这酷多了。我想，嗯，起初我开始真正发现，我发现了爵士乐和独特的，我真的发现了跨步钢琴，那对我来说实际上真的很酷。斯科特·乔普林。那是什么？跨步。
It's like, bom, bom, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, And so the way you play is like, it's a lot of jumping, striding, and you're doing. So it's a whole nother way. It almost sounds like boogie woogie, like a little bit. You know what I mean? It's the beginnings of it for sure.
就像，蹦，蹦，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，吧，所以你弹奏的方式就像，有很多跳跃，跨步，你在做。所以这是完全另一种方式。听起来几乎像布吉伍吉，有点像。你知道我的意思吗？这绝对是它的开端。
It was like the 20s and you know. And so it's really cool. And I remember my piano teacher used to make me play it blindfolded. And she was really trying to make sure that I could get out of trying to look and just try to find it. And it was terrifying. I was like, I can't, how can I reach?
就像20年代，你知道。所以这真的很酷。我记得我的钢琴老师过去常让我蒙着眼睛弹。她真的在试图确保我能摆脱试图看，只是试着找到它。这太可怕了。我当时想，我不能，我怎么能够到？
Luke Skywalker, right? What can I? And she was big on never apologize. Oh, I'm sorry, I messed up. Don't apologize, do not apologize. And if I made a mistake, she's like, I would go back. She's like, never go back, just keep going forward, right? Don't acknowledge the.
卢克·天行者，对吧？我能做什么？而且她非常强调从不道歉。哦，对不起，我搞砸了。不要道歉，不要道歉。如果我犯了错误，她就像，我会回去。她就像，永远不要回去，只是继续向前，对吧？不要承认那个。
The mistake, just go. And I think that taught me a lot. I think that taught me a lot to just like, just keep rolling, just keep trying to find your way through it. A great life lesson. Didn't always work, but just try to keep going. Yeah.
错误，只是走。而且我认为这教会了我很多。我认为这教会了我很多，只是就像，只是继续滚动，只是试着找到你的方式通过它。一个伟大的人生教训。并不总是有效，但只是试着继续前进。是的。
We'll be right back. And back to the show. So you end up going through high school. Did you go to like a performance arts type school? I did, I went to a performing arts junior high school, like seven, eight, nine, and then all the way through high school, professional performing arts school.
我们马上回来。回到节目。所以你最终读完了高中。你去了那种表演艺术学校吗？是的，我去了表演艺术初中，七、八、九年级，然后一直到高中，专业表演艺术学校。
It was like a small version of the fame school, so that was cool. But there, it was more music, it was more vocal, singing, arranging, and that's where I met my teacher, Miss Aziza, who actually, the character of Miss Liza Jane in Hell's Kitchen is inspired by Mrs. Eaza, that teacher, and my grandmother, kind of a mixture of the two of them.
它就像名声学校的小版本，所以那很酷。但在那里，更多的是音乐，更多的是声乐、唱歌、编曲，那是我遇到我的老师阿齐扎小姐的地方，实际上，《地狱厨房》中丽莎·简小姐的角色就是受伊扎老师和我的祖母启发，是两者的混合体。
And I met her there, and she was a big influence just on kind of like arranging and singing and harmonizing and creating and producing as a woman. And also when I put my eyes on Nina Simone, she was a woman that truly just blew my mind. I was like, oh. She's great. Oh, this is crazy. And that was the mixture of classical and R&B and soul and blues and that's why I started realizing, oh you can merge and
我在那里遇到了她，她对编曲、唱歌、和声、创作以及作为女性制作人产生了很大的影响。而且当我把目光投向尼娜·西蒙时，她是一个真正让我大脑爆炸的女性。我当时想，哦。她太棒了。哦，这太疯狂了。那是古典音乐、R&B、灵魂乐和蓝调的混合，这就是为什么我开始意识到，哦，你可以合并和
fuse these sounds and then hip-hop was a big inspiration for me just on the streets in New York. So it all kind of came together. It's such an exciting sound. We hope it works out for you. Thank you. Is that woman that was your mentor there at the Performing Arts School, is she still with us? Yes, and believe it or not, she plays piano for the Miss Liza Jean character in Hell's Kitchen. Oh my God, no way.
融合这些声音，然后嘻哈对我来说是一个很大的灵感，就在纽约的街头。所以这一切都融合在一起了。这真是一个令人兴奋的声音。我们希望这对你有效。谢谢。那个在表演艺术学校做你导师的女人，她还在我们身边吗？是的，信不信由你，她在《地狱厨房》中为丽莎·简小姐的角色弹钢琴。天哪，不会吧。
For real. That's so cool. It's insane, it's so cool. How cool is that? That was going to be my question, like did she get to see any of your success? So she's still here with us and is a part of it. Yeah.
真的。这太酷了。这太疯狂了，太酷了。那有多酷？那本来是我的问题，就像她能看到你的任何成功吗？所以她还在我们身边，是其中的一部分。是的。
It's a blessing. How rewarding is that? Very, very. I mean, when that was a conversation, and you know how on Broadway it's like quite, like all industries is quite institutionalized and there's like quite, like all industries, it's quite institutionalized and there's like kind of a way that things go with the thing and you hire the people that are always hired in the thing
这是一种祝福。那有多值得？非常，非常。我的意思是，当那是一个对话时，你知道百老汇就像相当，就像所有行业一样相当制度化，而且有像，就像所有行业一样，它相当制度化，而且有像，某种事情发生的方式，你雇佣那些总是被雇佣的人，
and you do the thing that's always done in the thing and so it was really a big, really a big part of it and I think everything is evolving now to really start to break through those traditions that are now ready to evolve and so to really bring to break through those traditions that are now ready to evolve. And so to really bring people into the mix that maybe aren't normally in it, really creates just another energy,
你做那些总是被做的事情，所以这真的是一个很大的，真的是其中的很大一部分，而且我认为一切都在进化，现在真正开始打破那些现在准备进化的传统，所以真正带来打破那些现在准备进化的传统。所以真正把人们带入混合中，也许通常不在其中，真的创造了另一种能量，
and I think you feel it. It is an interesting medium, right? Talking more about theater and Broadway specifically, the backbone of it is supported by the folks that have been going there for years and years and years, the subscription audience. And I'll bet that it's a very complicated and disciplined process to try to transition that
而且我想你能感觉到。这是一个有趣的媒介，对吧？更多地谈论戏剧和百老汇，它的骨干是由那些多年来一直去那里的人支持的，订阅观众。我敢打赌，试图过渡那是一个非常复杂和纪律严明的过程
with somewhat conservative audience into the more modern takes on art and what qualifies as entertainment nowadays and all this sort of atypical stuff. It's a really, a lot of interesting things going on there right now. Well, I would imagine, but what do you think, I wonder if a lot of those people also,
与有点保守的观众进入更现代的艺术观，以及现在什么算娱乐，以及所有这些非典型的东西。那里现在有很多有趣的事情发生。嗯，我会想象，但你怎么看，我想知道那些人中有很多也，
what percentage of them, when you do sign up for that, when that's your thing, you're kind of saying to a group of artists or a group saying, take me on a journey, like open my mind to new stuff. I'm here, I want to see what is new. Like it's a little bit of both, you know what I mean, probably? Yeah, you hope.
当你报名参加那个时，当那是你的事情时，你是在对一群艺术家或一群人说，带我踏上一段旅程，就像打开我的思想去接受新东西。我在这里，我想看看什么是新的。就像两者都有点，你知道我的意思吗，可能？是的，你希望。
I don't know. I think people want a great story. And I think that what happens is, when you're able to deliver a story, if it's a song, if it's a play, if it's a musical, if it's theater, if it's a film, if it's a piece of art, like if you're able to create this emotional connection, I do think that if you do it in a slightly different way, but they can follow the emotional arc of it,
我不知道。我认为人们想要一个伟大的故事。而且我认为发生的事情是，当你能够讲述一个故事时，如果它是一首歌，如果它是一部戏，如果它是一部音乐剧，如果它是戏剧，如果它是电影，如果它是一件艺术品，就像如果你能够创造这种情感联系，我确实认为如果你以稍微不同的方式做它，但他们可以跟随它的情感弧线，
then people are open. I think that's at the heart of a lot of things. Even with a great song, you might completely create a new genre, but when you have that song that you know you can sing and you feel it emotionally, it really doesn't actually matter ultimately. So I think there's something that people are looking for
那么人们是开放的。我认为这是许多事情的核心。即使是一首伟大的歌，你可能会完全创造一种新的流派，但当你拥有那首你知道你可以唱并且在情感上感受到它的歌时，它最终实际上并不重要。所以我认为人们正在寻找某种东西
that connects to them. Can I ask you a question? Jason's a real storyteller. I think he was something that people are looking for that connects to them. Can I ask you a question? Jason's a real storyteller. I think he was about to say that. Can I ask you about that? Because this is a little off topic, but speaking of drums, I always listen to just the drums in a song.
与他们联系起来。我可以问你一个问题吗？杰森是一个真正的讲故事的人。我想他是人们正在寻找某种东西与他们联系起来。我可以问你关于那个的问题吗？因为这有点离题，但说到鼓，我总是只听歌里的鼓。
Most people listen to the lyrics. I've tried to listen to the lyrics and train myself to be that kind of music, enjoy music in that way, but so often I can't hear what they're saying. And so to go to your point about if it's, you're telling a story through lyrics and through a song, do you ever battle with that when you're recording
大多数人听歌词。我试过听歌词并训练自己成为那种音乐，以那种方式享受音乐，但很多时候我听不清他们在说什么。所以回到你关于如果是，你通过歌词和歌曲讲故事的观点，当你在录音时，你是否曾经为此挣扎
and it just sounds better to kind of not enunciate a line, but then do you battle yourself going, yeah, but if they miss that line, they kind of miss a part of the story. Do you ever have that struggle as a singer? That's a good point. I mean, there is definitely lines that just because of the emotion of it or the way that you want to deliver it,
而且听起来不咬字清晰更好，但然后你是否会挣扎，是的，但如果他们错过了那一行，他们就错过了一部分故事。作为歌手，你是否有过那种挣扎？这是一个很好的点。我的意思是，确实有一些台词只是因为它的情感或你想要交付它的方式，
it might not be as clear as ever. And definitely that's more even now, like there is like this way of delivering that, not necessarily clear, but as the songwriter, because I am the songwriter, I do feel connected to wanting the lyrics to connect to each other. You know, I want them to like. And to be clear so that people can kind of follow.
它可能不像以往那样清晰。而且绝对现在更是如此，就像有那种交付方式，不一定清晰，但作为词曲作者，因为我是词曲作者，我确实感到有联系，想要歌词相互联系。你知道，我想要它们像。并且要清晰，以便人们可以跟随。
Jason, you used to always think that song was, I want to know who Doug is, right? You always think that. That always happens. We'll be honest though, the last time, I used to always think that song was, I wanna know who Doug is. Right, you always think that. That always happens. We'll be honest though, one of the last times I looked up lyrics, because I was a part of a song I just couldn't understand,
杰森，你过去总是认为那首歌是，我想知道道格是谁，对吧？你总是那样想。那总是发生。我们诚实一点，上次，我过去总是认为那首歌是，我想知道道格是谁。对，你总是那样想。那总是发生。我们诚实一点，我最后几次查歌词之一，因为我是我无法理解的歌曲的一部分，
and now feel like an idiot that I didn't, was concrete jungle where dreams are made of. I was just like, oh yeah, that fits. People have all types of, they say concrete, jungle, wet dreams, tomatoes, they have all kinds of crazy. I have one, it was an old song from the 80s, from a group called Till Tuesday, Amy Mayer. And it was Hush, it was Hush, Hush.
现在感觉自己像个白痴，我没有，是混凝土丛林，梦想成真。我当时只是想，哦是的，那很合适。人们有各种各样的，他们说混凝土，丛林，湿梦，西红柿，他们有各种各样的疯狂。我有一个，那是80年代的一首老歌，来自一个叫Till Tuesday的团体，艾米·梅耶。那是嘘，那是嘘，
Hush is carry. Yes, and the lyrics are, Hush, hush, keep it down now, voices carry. And all through high school I was like, Hush, hush, we go downtown, it's so scary. Oh my God. Wait, wait a second. This is awful.
嘘是携带。是的，歌词是，嘘，嘘，保持安静，声音传播。整个高中我都在想，嘘，嘘，我们去市中心，太可怕了。天哪。等等，等一下。这太糟糕了。
Wait a second, I want to say, because JB you brought it up, Empire State of Mind, I mean that song is, it must be kind of. It's an anthem. It is an anthem. Thank you. It's such an iconic song. I mean, that song is, it must be kind of... An anthem. It is an anthem. It's such an iconic song, an iconic song about New York. It's so emblematic of a time.
等一下，我想说，因为JB你提到了，帝国心态，我的意思是那首歌是，它一定有点。这是一首赞歌。这是一首赞歌。谢谢。这是一首如此标志性的歌。我的意思是，那首歌是，它一定有点……赞歌。这是一首赞歌。这是一首如此标志性的歌，一首关于纽约的标志性歌曲。它如此象征着一个时代。
There is part, I love that, I don't think that there's anybody who hears that song who doesn't turn it up and feel good. And even those sort of millennial white chicks are like, that's my fucking jam. I think it's replaced, it's the modern day Frank Sinatra version of New York, New York.
有一部分我特别喜欢，我想任何听到那首歌的人都会把它调大声，然后感觉很棒。甚至那些千禧一代的白人女孩也会说，这简直是我的心头好。我觉得它已经取代了弗兰克·辛纳屈那首《纽约，纽约》，成为了现代版的纽约之歌。
It's the new anthem. Alicia, it's incredible. Do you feel, not a burden, I don't want to say a burden, but just not a burden, because don't want to say a burden, but like just not a burden, that's a, because that's a sort of, has a negative connotation, but do you, are you able to appreciate or understand how meaningful that song is?
这是新的赞歌。艾丽西亚，这太不可思议了。你是否感到——不是负担，我不想说负担，因为这词有负面含义——你是否能体会或理解那首歌有多么深刻的意义？
I feel so like stunned by many of the songs that like become a soundtrack to people's life. It's like crazy. Yeah. And for it to just live and evolve and continue to be like a staple like that, but particularly for my hometown. I mean, that is my home town. And the craziest part is, you know,
很多歌曲成为了人们生活的背景音乐，这让我感到非常震撼。这太疯狂了。是的。它能一直流传、演变，并成为像那样的经典，尤其是对于我的家乡来说。我的意思是，那是我的家乡。最疯狂的部分是，你知道，
there was a moment where that song wasn't even going to happen. Or it wasn't going to happen with me because there were some things at the time, and Jay was kind of trying to get in touch with me about doing the song, and at the time, the people that I was working with, whatever happened, it just didn't get to me. And he was going to have to move on,
曾经有一刻，那首歌甚至差点没能诞生。或者说它差点没能由我来演唱，因为当时出了一些状况，Jay-Z当时正试图联系我来唱这首歌，但当时和我共事的人，不管发生了什么，消息没传到我这儿。他本来打算放弃了，
because he was like, I don't know, it's not working out, I can't get a response, it's not going to happen. Literally just because he couldn't get in touch. I find it going to happen. Literally just because he couldn't get in touch. I find it so hard to believe that Jay-Z couldn't get in touch with Alicia Keys. You know what I mean? Your reps were putting up too high a wall. It wasn't progressing in the way that needed to happen
因为他觉得，我不知道，这事儿成不了，我得不到回应，这歌没戏了。真的就因为他联系不上我。我简直不敢相信Jay-Z竟然联系不上艾丽西亚·凯斯。你懂我的意思吗？你的经纪团队筑起的墙太高了。事情没有按照预期的方向发展，
to make it happen and I wasn't aware of that. Fortunately, he was friends with a friend of mine and that was kind of how we got a chance to connect and I was like, what? What do you mean? You haven't heard from me. Here I am, what do you mean? Isn't that funny?
没能促成合作，而我对此一无所知。幸运的是，他和我的一个朋友是朋友，我们就是这样才有了联系的机会。我当时就说，什么？你什么意思？你没收到我的消息？我就在这儿啊，你什么意思？这难道不滑稽吗？
Everybody from the outside, like my idea, it's like, oh, everybody in the music world must know each other, everybody. You know, we know, we definitely, you know a lot of people, and you connect in a lot of ways, and then sometimes you don't, you know, so. There's no hotline. Right, let me call these.
局外人都觉得，哦，音乐圈里的每个人肯定都互相认识。你知道，我们确实认识很多人，也通过各种方式建立联系，但有时也会断联，所以。并没有什么热线电话。对，让我打给这些人。
So thank goodness that happened, because man, it would have been crazy for it to not happen. And so that, and hearing the way that song has taken just its own place in the universe. What was that process like recording that song as much as you're comfortable talking about? Like how did that sort of, so he gets in touch with you and he's like what, how's Tuesday at 11?
所以谢天谢地，最后还是成了，因为天哪，如果没成那才叫疯狂。听到那首歌在宇宙中占据了属于它自己的位置，那种感觉……录制那首歌的过程是怎样的？在你愿意分享的范围内。比如，他是怎么联系上你的？他说的是，周二11点怎么样？
So was it his song that he brought you into or vice versa? He had begun the song so he was like here's the vibe of it, here's the beginning of it. Because you're a songwriter on it as well. Correct. And there are also other tremendous songwriters on it. So it's like, it's one of those songs that had that right collaboration of all the right people together. And so it had the beginnings of it.
所以那是他带你加入的歌，还是反过来？他已经开始了这首歌的创作，所以他说，这是它的基调，这是开头。因为你也是这首歌的词曲作者之一。没错。而且还有其他非常出色的词曲作者参与其中。所以，这首歌汇集了所有合适的人，是一次完美的合作。它当时已经有了雏形。
And it was starting to really take shape. And when I heard it, I was like, his lyrics weren't even completely finished. He maybe had like a beginning of a verse, but you could tell, you could just feel it. Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba. All the parts were just incredible and so I was like, man, we got to do this ASAP. And I remember the soonest I could do it, I was in LA.
它开始真正成型了。当我听到它的时候，我觉得，他的歌词甚至还没完全写完。他可能只有一段主歌的开头，但你能感觉到，你真的能感受到。哒哒哒哒哒哒……所有的部分都太棒了，所以我说，伙计，我们得尽快把它做出来。我记得我能做的最早时间，我当时在洛杉矶。
And so I was like, all right, I'll cut it while I'm in LA. And I was there and I wasn't feeling the best. I was a little bit sick. I was on tour. I was a little bit run down. So I sing the song, I gave it my all. I sing it, I send it back. And he's like...
所以我说，好吧，我在洛杉矶的时候把它录了。我在那儿，但感觉不太好。我有点生病了。我当时在巡演，身体有点透支。所以我唱了这首歌，我尽了全力。我唱完，发回给他。然后他说……
We'll be in touch. Yeah. Do you think you could sing it one more time? And I was like, what? Like, what do you mean, sing it one more time? And I was like, what? Like, what do you mean, sing it one more time? What do you mean? Why do I have to sing it one more time? But I was sick.
我们会再联系的。是的。你觉得你能再唱一遍吗？我当时就想，什么？什么叫再唱一遍？什么意思？为什么我非得再唱一遍？但我当时生病了。
I mean, we can't sing a New York song in LA. It's just like, you got to be in the space. I've said that to Sean so many times. Yeah, so many. So we were able to take it back again. He was like, could you put some of that, when you go, uh, yeah, uh, can you do some of all that,
我的意思是，我们不能在洛杉矶唱一首关于纽约的歌。你必须身临其境。我跟肖恩说过很多次了。是的，很多次。所以我们又重新录了一次。他说，当你唱到“嗯，耶，嗯”的时候，能不能加点那种感觉，
and then do it one more time. He said that he had to think about how he was going to call me and tell me this for a decent amount of time. He was like, how am I saying this in a way that feels encouraging? But sure enough, I got back to my studio in New York. It was the right time, I felt much better.
然后再唱一遍。他说他想了很久该怎么打电话告诉我这件事。他在想，我该怎么说才能让人觉得是在鼓励？但果然，我回到纽约的工作室后，时机对了，我感觉好多了。
We delivered the whole thing, and that's when it really got that magic, and that's the version that you hear when we re-did it again. It's pretty funny, but it was great. Have you guys performed it together? I think even at the Tonys, I feel like he was on a different stage maybe.
我们交付了最终版本，那才是它真正产生魔力的时候，也就是你现在听到的那个版本。这挺有趣的，但结果很棒。你们一起表演过吗？我觉得甚至在托尼奖颁奖礼上，我感觉他好像在另一个舞台上？
Uh-huh, we performed it at the Tonys together. We performed it at the Tonys, I feel like he was on a different stage, maybe, or... Uh-huh, we performed it at the Tonys together. We performed it at the World Series, of the Yankees World Series. That was one of the first plays we performed in. Oh my God, I gotta look that up. And then we did another one, maybe it was like the AMAs, or something like that. So we maybe three times, like three or four times we've done.
嗯哼，我们在托尼奖上一起表演过。我们在托尼奖上表演过，我感觉他可能在另一个舞台上，或者……嗯哼，我们在托尼奖上一起表演过。我们在洋基队的世界大赛上也表演过。那是我们最早表演的地方之一。天哪，我得去查查。然后我们还做过一次，可能是全美音乐奖之类的。所以我们大概表演过三四次。
We did one where I took over Times Square and the whole Times Square and every building had. Oh, I'm going to look that up too. Was that shot? That must be on YouTube. That was insane. That must have been, I mean, by the way, also, not just in New York, if you're in Times Square,
有一次我占领了时代广场，整个时代广场的每一栋建筑都有。哦，我也要去查查。那是拍下来的吗？那一定在YouTube上。那太疯狂了。那一定，顺便说一句，不仅是在纽约，如果你在时代广场，
you're blocks away from where you grew up. Like, you're right there. I remember getting off the stage that night and I was like, if this is my last day, I'm good. Like I'm good, I feel like I'm good. Well like. That's what Sean said when he walked out of an Arby's once. And they had all the horsey suss he could handle.
你离你长大的地方只有几个街区远。就像，你就在那儿。我记得那天晚上走下舞台时，我想，如果这是我的最后一天，我也知足了。我感觉很好。就像肖恩有次走出一家阿比快餐店时说的话。他们有他能吃到的所有辣根酱。
So. I stole some of that suss once. Did you ever allow yourself to even dream of things like that when you were, and is this true, when you signed your first record with your first record label at 15, did you think, well, I am starting nice and young here, things are looking good, something like performing in Times Square, getting Tonys, Grammys, all that stuff, that is possible? Did you allow yourself to dream that big?
所以。我曾经偷过一些那种酱。你有没有允许自己梦想过这样的事情？这是真的吗？当你15岁签下第一份唱片合同时，你有没有想过，好吧，我起步不错，很年轻，一切看起来都很好，像在时代广场表演、拿托尼奖、格莱美奖这些事，是有可能的吗？你允许自己做那么大的梦吗？
I feel like there's things that you definitely dream of, and I do feel like the big stage singing in front of the mirror, like, one day they'll all sing my songs. I do remember having those moments because you were, you know, you're looking at a Whitney Houston or a Michael Jackson and you're like, man, maybe one day would it be like that? I do remember having those moments, because you were looking at a Whitney Houston or a Michael Jackson, and you're like, man, maybe one day would it be like that. I remember feeling like that. I do recall that when we, speaking of the Times Square,
我觉得有些事情你确实会去梦想，我确实记得对着镜子唱歌，想着有一天他们都会唱我的歌。我记得有过那些时刻，因为你看着惠特尼·休斯顿或迈克尔·杰克逊，你会想，天哪，也许有一天我也能那样？我记得有过那些时刻，因为你看着惠特尼·休斯顿或迈克尔·杰克逊，你会想，天哪，也许有一天我也能那样。我记得那种感觉。我确实记得，说到时代广场，
when we did take over Times Square, I remember feeling like I never dreamed this big before. Like I never even thought that something like this. So what does that do? Does it make you nervous when it hits you like that? Does it, do you get like, does it, are you like, gosh, I don't know if I'm deserving of this. This is weird, this is freaky.
当我们占领时代广场时，我记得我感觉自己从未做过这么大的梦。我甚至从未想过会有这样的事情。那会带来什么影响？当这种感觉袭来时，你会紧张吗？你会觉得，天哪，我不知道我是否配得上这一切。这很奇怪，这很诡异。
Or did you like, you know what, I worked hard, I deserve to be here. Like what was the emotion behind that when you first felt that? I definitely have gone through my don't deserve this phase for sure. Had plenty of that. I woke up that way.
还是你会想，你知道吗，我努力工作了，我理应在这里。当你第一次感受到那种情绪时，背后的想法是什么？我肯定经历过“我不配”的阶段，绝对经历过。我有过很多次那种感觉。我醒来时就是那种状态。
All of us. Get in line, yeah. But I think that in that moment, I felt like this adrenaline, this like unbelievable adrenaline. I'm like, we shut down the entire Times Square. There's 2,000 cops out here making sure that all the people have their place to be. We have every screen.
我们都有过。排队吧，是的。但我认为在那一刻，我感到一种肾上腺素，一种难以置信的肾上腺素。我想，我们封锁了整个时代广场。这里有2000名警察确保所有人的位置。我们有所有的屏幕。
We meticulously chose how each screen is going to reflect the songs we're singing. I was like, this John Mayer's coming out, Jay-Z's coming out, Questlove is playing drums. I'm like, this shit is out of control. I more felt like a disbelief, like an adrenaline excitement. Pinch me, how did this happen? Oh, so you were there, you were present. Well, I bet, yeah, and I bet if? Yeah, I'll see, you were there, you were present.
我们精心选择了每个屏幕如何反映我们唱的歌。我想，约翰·梅尔要出来了，Jay-Z要出来了，奎斯特拉夫在打鼓。我想，这简直太疯狂了。我更多的是一种难以置信，一种肾上腺素带来的兴奋。掐我一下，这是怎么发生的？哦，所以你在那儿，你在现场。好吧，我敢打赌，是的，如果你？是的，你看，你在那儿，你在现场。
Yeah, and I bet because, like you said, having that moment of saying, I never dreamed this big, this is beyond what I thought, you almost don't have a chance maybe to be nervous because you have no preconceived notion of being in this situation. That's a good one. You know what I mean?
是的，我敢打赌，就像你说的，当你那一刻说“我从未做过这么大的梦，这超出了我的想象”，你可能几乎没有机会感到紧张，因为你对处于这种境地没有任何先入为主的概念。这话说得好。你懂我的意思吗？
That's a good one. I mean, you feel nervous because I feel like that's a healthy emotion. Like, you know, you feel those, that's why I guess it's adrenaline more, because you feel like that energy and you feel like, whoa, let me, let me. And I think what I do remember though, especially during this time,
这话说得好。我的意思是，你会感到紧张，因为我觉得那是一种健康的情绪。就像，你知道，你感受到了那些，我想这就是为什么它是肾上腺素，因为你感受到了那种能量，你觉得，哇，让我，让我。但我确实记得，特别是在那段时间，
I remember feeling like I was starting to talk to myself about being comfortable being great. I wanted to become comfortable being great and not somehow kind of getting in my own way for it. And that's actually a conversation that I have to have often with myself. Like, you're going to take this moment and you're allowed to execute this moment
我记得我开始对自己说要习惯变得伟大。我想让自己习惯变得伟大，而不是以某种方式阻碍自己。这实际上是我经常要对自己进行的对话。比如，你要抓住这一刻，你有权发挥这一刻
to the highest capacity, as opposed to like, I'ma fuck this up, this ain't gonna go right. This, you know, all these things that we allow in our head. Playing defense. So I just like, I remember I was talking to myself in that way, so I was like, go, like go, go, just go. And I felt it.
到最高水平，而不是想，我会搞砸的，这不会顺利的。这，你知道，所有这些我们允许出现在脑子里的想法。在进行防御。所以我只是，我记得我当时就是那样对自己说话的，所以我说，去吧，去吧，去吧，就去吧。我感觉到了。
That is so evolved. That is, I know, I'm gonna write that down. I don't need to write it down because I never, I'm not. I wanna tattoo that somewhere. I never have to worry about getting, being great, so I don't have to worry about it. Will, don't you say that, Will. No, it's okay.
那太成熟了。那，我知道，我要把它写下来。我不需要写下来，因为我从来，我不是。我想把它纹在什么地方。我永远不用担心变得伟大，所以我不用担心它。威尔，别那么说，威尔。不，没关系。
Will, William, get over here, right now. Wait, wait. Is that a double negative or like a double positive? No, I know, I'm just, I'm leaving the door open for all you guys to go. Compliments and stuff like that. Alicia, where did, you know, I'm leaving the door open for all you guys to go. Compliments and stuff like that. Alicia, we're talking about that sort of, God, writing this song, and all the right,
威尔，威廉，过来，现在。等等，等等。那是双重否定还是双重肯定？不，我知道，我只是，我给你们所有人留着门呢。赞美之类的。艾丽西亚，哪里，你知道，我给你们所有人留着门呢。赞美之类的。艾丽西亚，我们刚才在谈论那种，天哪，写这首歌，以及所有正确的，
when did you start, when's the moment, I'm always interested when you're playing and you're learning how to play and you're going through and you're developing your skill and all that and your artistry, and then when do you start writing a song? When do you have the audacity to write a song? Like I wouldn't have the guts to, you know? I love that question.
你什么时候开始的，那一刻是什么时候？我一直很好奇，当你演奏、学习演奏、不断发展你的技能和艺术造诣时，你什么时候开始写歌的？你什么时候有勇气写歌的？比如我就没有那个胆量，你知道吗？我喜欢这个问题。
My first, the first time I had the audacity to write a song was 11. And it was actually a really important moment because I had lost my grandfather and that was the first kind of big loss in my life in that way that just felt so like, whoa, I didn't know what to do with it. And it was the first time that I was moved to write
我第一次有勇气写歌是在11岁。那实际上是一个非常重要的时刻，因为我失去了祖父，那是我生命中第一次经历那种重大的失去，感觉就像，哇，我不知道该怎么办。那是我第一次被触动去写歌，
because I felt something that was so genuine that I had to write the thing. And that was the basis of how I learned how to song write. And so that's actually my style of writing. I write because I feel the thing to write. And so even though it was a sad time for me, I do feel like it connected me with the idea of how do you bring out whatever that emotion is
因为我感受到了如此真实的东西，我必须把它写下来。那就是我学习写歌的基础。所以这实际上就是我的写作风格。我写是因为我感受到了要写的东西。所以尽管那对我来说是一段悲伤的时光，但我确实觉得它让我明白了如何将那种情绪带入
into real life. And so that was when I first wrote. That was my first song. My second song I wrote at 14, and that actually made it on my first album. And that was kind of like because it was my first love, and I just at 14, and that was, that actually made it on my first album. And that was kind of like, because it was my first love, and I just had this feeling, and I never felt that feeling before,
现实生活中。所以那就是我第一次写歌的时候。那是我的第一首歌。我14岁时写了第二首歌，那首歌实际上被收录进了我的第一张专辑。那是因为那是我的初恋，我只是在14岁时，那实际上被收录进了我的第一张专辑。那是因为那是我的初恋，我只是有这种感觉，我以前从未有过那种感觉，
and so I wrote that type of feeling down. And that song's called Butterflies, and that's on the first album. And that was kind of my first other one. And then from there, you know, other things kind of flew. Well, so, now, so that first album was Songs in A Minor? Yes, yes. And was a big hit, massive success.
所以我把那种感觉写了下来。那首歌叫《蝴蝶》，收录在第一张专辑里。那算是我的第一首其他的歌。从那以后，你知道，其他事情就顺其自然了。那么，现在，第一张专辑是《Songs in A Minor》？是的，是的。那是一次巨大的成功，巨大的成功。
Yeah, and so when you walk into your second album, did you allow yourself to be great or were you playing defense? How early on did you start to kind of lean forward and go, okay, let's get going and let's have a long career here? I mean, it was definitely always the talk of the sophomore jinx.
是的，所以当你开始制作第二张专辑时，你允许自己变得伟大，还是在进行防御？你多早就开始向前倾，说，好吧，让我们开始吧，让我们在这里拥有长久的职业生涯？我的意思是，这绝对一直是关于“大二魔咒”的讨论。
I mean, people always say that's when it, you get your whole life to write your first album and then you get like two months to write the next one or whatever it is. But I remember feeling pretty supported to be able to go in and just start to craft and play. It was my, I had just come off my first tour. That was like a mind bender,
我的意思是，人们总是说那是，你用一辈子去写第一张专辑，然后你只有两个月的时间去写下一张，或者不管是什么。但我记得我感到相当受支持，能够进去开始创作和演奏。那是我，我刚结束第一次巡演。那简直让人头晕目眩，
because I was just like, what are all these people doing here? Why are they here? And when I was able to kind of release that and be back into a quiet space back in New York, it felt really nice just to be in that universe. I didn't, at the time, I thought I had to work every hour of every day of every minute of every second
因为我当时想，这些人都在这儿干什么？他们为什么在这儿？当我能够释放那种感觉，回到纽约一个安静的空间时，回到那个世界感觉真的很棒。我当时并没有，我以为我必须每天每小时每分钟每秒都在工作，
because I had to deliver this thing. So I didn't understand the balance yet of how do you actually enjoy and then create, and I didn't have that down yet. But I felt like I had time to create. And then all of a sudden, once we found the first song, then time kind of got cut short. And they were like, now we're moving, let's go.
因为我必须交付这个东西。所以我还不明白如何享受生活然后进行创作的平衡，我还没掌握这一点。但我感觉我有时间去创作。然后突然间，一旦我们找到了第一首歌，时间就变得紧迫了。他们说，现在我们要行动了，走吧。
So that was actually a very difficult process because I was continuing to write and promoting the record before the record was finished. And that was hard for me as like 22 or 21 or whatever I was at that time. I remember just asking, because I was in Europe and we started in Europe, and I asked them to please sit me in a restaurant for whatever 800 hours
所以那实际上是一个非常困难的过程，因为我在唱片完成之前还在继续写歌和宣传。对于当时21或22岁的我来说，这很难。我记得我只是请求，因为我在欧洲，我们从欧洲开始，我请求他们让我坐在餐馆里，不管我们要做的800小时
of interviews that we were doing so I could see the Eiffel Tower when we were in Paris. I said, I just want to see the Eiffel Tower. While I'm here. Yeah. That's hysterical. Actually, that's a really great move. I really like that. Because you're like, hey, if I'm going to be stuck here doing this.
采访，这样我就可以在巴黎时看到埃菲尔铁塔。我说，我只想看埃菲尔铁塔。当我在那儿的时候。是的。那太搞笑了。实际上，那是一个非常棒的举动。我真的很喜欢。因为你会想，嘿，如果我非得被困在这里做这些事。
I want to look at something nice. Yeah, I want my experience to be kind of good. In the place, in the space. You know what? That's a really good sign of self-care. You've got like a healthy dose of self care in you. I like that. Speaking of self care, you've got, you've got a, you've branched out into a,
我想看点好的东西。是的，我想让我的体验变得好一点。在那个地方，在那个空间。你知道吗？这是一个很好的自我关怀的标志。你身上有一种健康的自我关怀。我喜欢这个。说到自我关怀，你，你有一个，你涉足了一个，
is it, how would you qualify, a skincare line? No. I would call it a lifestyle, I would call it a lifestyle brand, but it is based in, it's called Soul Care. And it is based in these offerings of skin care or body care that really give you the opportunity to connect with a deeper part of yourself.
是吗，你怎么定义，护肤系列？不。我会称之为生活方式，我会称之为生活方式品牌，但它基于，它叫“灵魂关怀”（Soul Care）。它基于这些护肤或身体护理产品，真正让你有机会与内心深处建立联系。
And so we have affirmations on every bottle, and everything is kind of, you know, there's crystals and ancient rituals and all these beautiful organic ingredients that really help. Well yeah, let me tell you that the skin thing is working because your skin is like perfect. You look 12. Thank you.
所以我们在每个瓶子上都有肯定语，一切都是，你知道，有水晶和古老的仪式，还有所有这些美丽的有机成分，真的很有帮助。好吧，让我告诉你，护肤品确实有效，因为你的皮肤简直完美。你看上去像12岁。谢谢。
Well listen, I'm just happy that we're not going to use this recording because I'm like great, I can just jump out the shower. That's why we don't release the video, exactly. Thank you. Yeah, they don't have to worry about what they're going to wear, what their hair's looking like, what the key exactly is. So thank you, thank you like, what the exact.
好吧，听着，我很高兴我们不会使用这段录音，因为我想，太好了，我可以刚洗完澡就出来。这就是为什么我们不发布视频，没错。谢谢。是的，他们不必担心穿什么，头发看起来怎么样，关键到底是什么。所以谢谢，谢谢，像，到底是什么。
So thank you, thank you. It's the best. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Now, going back to allow yourself to be great, I would imagine the roots of that, if not verbatim, was given to you by an adult in your life when you were younger. And if that was your mom, do you, have you had that,
所以谢谢，谢谢。这是最好的。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。现在，回到允许自己变得伟大，我想象那根源，如果不是逐字逐句，是你年轻时生活中的一位成年人告诉你的。如果是你妈妈，你，你经历过那个吗，
you have children now, are they, have you had that yet? Do you enjoy sharing that and helping, you know, these little birds jump out of the nest? I do. I mean, it's really incredible, the conversations that we have. And also just like observing them and seeing what they're feeling
你现在有孩子了，他们，你经历过那个了吗？你喜欢分享并帮助，你知道，这些小鸟飞出巢穴吗？我喜欢。我的意思是，我们进行的对话真的很不可思议。还有就是观察他们，看看他们的感受
and what they're experiencing. And also allowing them to draw their own conclusions too, which is unique because I think sometimes as parents or as people who have more experience, you always want to kind of lay your whole thing on a person sometimes. Cut some corners for them. You do, you're like, if you just listen to me, I swear.
以及他们正在经历什么。还有允许他们自己得出结论，这很独特，因为我觉得有时作为父母或作为更有经验的人，你总是想把你的整套东西强加给一个人。为他们走捷径。你会的，你会说，如果你只是听我的，我发誓。
I know. Kids, home and parents are the last place kids and people kids listen to, right? It seems like the older they get, especially in teenage years, you guys tell me, I don't have kids, but it always seems like their lessons and the inspiration and the motivation always come from outside sources,
我知道。孩子，家和父母是孩子和人们最不听的地方，对吧？看起来他们越大，特别是在青少年时期，你们告诉我，我没有孩子，但看起来他们的课程、灵感和动力总是来自外部来源，
which is so weird because as a parent, like Jason, like you're saying, you're just like, no, but listen to what I'm telling you. Right, but they need to like make their own scars too. Yeah, because it's just noise, I guess, after a while. But they do have, I have all boys, and my teenage boys, I'm always like, well, don't take my word for it.
这太奇怪了，因为作为父母，就像杰森，就像你说的，你只是说，不，但听听我在告诉你什么。对，但他们也需要像制造自己的伤疤一样。是的，因为我觉得过了一会儿，那只是噪音。但他们确实有，我有全是男孩，我的十几岁的儿子，我总是说，好吧，别听我的话。
I mean, I only got this far, and they're like, whatever. Yeah, but they don't, they're like, sure, whatever. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, right. You know, I think that, I do think they definitely get a lot from outside, and especially now, like all of the phones, the social medias, like crazy the amount of information that they're getting,
我的意思是，我只走到这一步，他们说，随便吧。是的，但他们没有，他们说，当然，随便吧。是的，没错。你知道，我认为，我确实认为他们肯定从外部得到了很多，特别是现在，像所有的手机，社交媒体，像他们得到的信息量太疯狂了，
which some of it is like incredible. Like they're actually leaps and bounds ahead of us in so many ways, and some of it is just like, man, there's so much to figure out what's real and what's not real, and what do you learn from that, or what do you take from that? So I think although they are getting a lot of information from outside, they do know, if you open a door,
其中一些就像不可思议。就像他们在很多方面实际上比我们领先几光年，而其中一些就像，天哪，有太多东西要弄清楚什么是真的，什么是假的，你从中学到什么，或者你从中得到什么？所以我认为尽管他们从外部得到了很多信息，但他们确实知道，如果你打开一扇门，
they do know that they can trust when they speak with you that they can kind of share their thoughts and it is a safe place. I'm always, yes, that's a good point. I'm always surprised, I'm going back on what I just said. I'm always surprised when there are parents who've done it correctly where the kids do listen to what their parents say
他们确实知道，当你和他们交谈时，他们可以信任，他们可以分享他们的想法，这是一个安全的地方。我总是，是的，这是一个好点。我总是很惊讶，我收回我刚才说的话。我总是很惊讶，当有父母做得正确，孩子确实听父母说的话
and they do listen. And there's a respect there that the parents have taught the kids so that as they get older, they actually listen to what their parents say. I've witnessed this both sides, both versions. I think they hear you. Sometimes they might not do exactly what you want them to do
并且他们确实听。父母教给孩子一种尊重，这样当他们长大后，他们实际上会听父母说的话。我目睹了这两面，两个版本。我想他们听到了。有时他们可能不会完全按照你想要他们做的方式去做
or you're hoping they do, but they do internalize what you're saying and it comes out in different points. And what I've started hearing more and more lately and I think I'm a believer in it is that as articulate as you can be, as profound as you can be with the shit you tell your kid, really the thing that penetrates and holds with them
或者你希望他们做，但他们确实内化了你所说的话，它在不同的点上表现出来。我最近开始听到越来越多，我想我是它的信徒，那就是，你能表达得多么清晰，你能对你告诉孩子的事情多么深刻，真正渗透并保持在他们心中的东西
is example. Like they watch you. They watch you do what you do and not what you do. Yeah, living a good example, I think, is the best thing you can give your kid. I think that's true and I think that goes for kind of all relationships too. I think just with people in general and you know,
是榜样。就像他们看着你。他们看着你做你做的事，而不是你做的事。是的，过一个好的榜样，我认为是你给孩子最好的东西。我认为这是真的，我认为这也适用于各种关系。我认为只是和人们在一起，你知道，
I have a good friend, we talk about this all the time, which is you can't really coach people up, you can only model it. And yeah, especially people you're really close with. It's really tough in interpersonal relationship to coach them up to say like, hey, you need to be doing this or hey, this is how, and all you can do and certainly it goes, JB,
我有一个好朋友，我们一直谈论这个，那就是你不能真正指导人们，你只能模拟它。是的，特别是你非常亲近的人。在人际关系中指导他们说，嘿，你需要做这个，或者嘿，这就是怎么做，这真的很难，你所能做的，当然，它去了，JB，
to what you're saying, like it goes like that for your kids. You just model it and you just behave a certain way. And your kids, what I know, again, no expert, but my kids, my reaction to stuff gives them a lot of information. That's great. So if they get a bad grade or if they get a thing like that, if how I react to it is really important
到你所说的，就像它对你的孩子那样。你只是模拟它，你只是表现出某种方式。而你的孩子，我所知道的，再次，不是专家，但我的孩子，我对事情的反应给了他们很多信息。那太棒了。所以如果他们成绩不好，或者如果他们有那样的事情，如果我对此的反应真的很重要
in informing them on how that they should. Yeah, I think you're saying. Yeah. I wanna talk about, we're almost out of time here, we don't wanna let you get back in your busy life, but your passion for art and your considerable collection with your husband, talk to me about that.
在告知他们应该如何做方面。是的，我想你在说。是的。我想谈谈，我们快没时间了，我们不想让你回到你忙碌的生活中，但你对艺术的热情和你与丈夫相当大的收藏，跟我谈谈那个。
I know that you enjoy discovering and supporting new and emerging artists. And did it start with that, your fascination with art, your passion for art, or was that just a part that became sort of the philanthropy of it all? Man, no, I mean, my husband really is an incredible lover of art, and he has an uncanny ability to really identify artists that are going to be the next, next, and the next. And so it's unreal.
我知道你喜欢发现和支持新的和新兴的艺术家。它是从那个开始的吗，你对艺术的迷恋，你对艺术的热情，还是那只是成为这一切慈善事业的一部分？天哪，不，我的意思是，我丈夫确实是一个不可思议的艺术爱好者，他有一种不可思议的能力，能够真正识别出将成为下一个、下一个和下一个的艺术家。所以这太不真实了。
And that's because he actually, we are artists, obviously, he also is an artist who draws and paints. And so there's this real genuine love for the art that I think comes from being artists and connecting with artists. And also being in position of owning our art and being the custodians of art in a way that is protecting it, not just exploiting it.
那是因为他实际上，我们是艺术家，显然，他也是一个画画和绘画的艺术家。所以有一种对艺术的真正真诚的爱，我认为来自于成为艺术家并与艺术家建立联系。还有处于拥有我们艺术的地位，并以保护它而不是仅仅剥削它的方式成为艺术的保管人。
And so that- But you're displaying it too, right? Isn't your collection a portion of it on tour right now? Is that what you're calling it? It is, it started at the Brooklyn Museum. It's called Giants. We called it Giants because it's all these oversize works of artists.
所以那个——但你也在展示它，对吧？你的收藏的一部分现在不是在巡演吗？那是你称之为那个的东西吗？是的，它始于布鲁克林博物馆。它叫“巨人”。我们称之为“巨人”，因为它是所有这些艺术家的超大作品。
And it is also, we consider the artists in the exhibition, giants of their craft, their masterpieces. And you hate the Jets. And what? And you hate the Jets. Because of the Jets. Right. And the Dodgers.
而且它也是，我们认为展览中的艺术家是他们工艺的巨人，他们的杰作。而且你讨厌喷气机队。什么？而且你讨厌喷气机队。因为喷气机队。对。还有道奇队。
My head was like, wait, wait, what, what, what? Who are the artists, wait, Alicia, who are the artists I'm really interested, I'm so jealous of you, who are the artists that you really, that are exciting you right now? And they don't have to be new, like what are the things? There's so many incredible, unbelievable artists. I mean, in Giants, we actually just opened it
我的头脑就像，等等，等等，什么，什么，什么？谁是艺术家，等等，艾丽西亚，谁是艺术家，我真的很感兴趣，我真的很嫉妒你，谁是你真正感兴趣的艺术家，那些让你兴奋的艺术家？他们不必是新的，比如那些东西是什么？有这么多不可思议的、难以置信的艺术家。我的意思是，在“巨人”中，我们实际上刚刚开放了
at the High Museum, so it's touring now in Atlanta at the High Museum, and man, all of the artists in this exhibition are completely tremendous. Jordan Castile is a beautiful young artist that we adore. Amy Sherald is super incredible. And when you see these works of art, it's unbelievable. Jamel Shabazz is paired with Gordon Parks. So you see the photography side of the lens
在高等艺术博物馆，所以它现在在亚特兰大的高等艺术博物馆巡演，天哪，这个展览中的所有艺术家都非常了不起。乔丹·卡斯蒂尔是一位美丽的年轻艺术家，我们崇拜她。艾米·谢拉德超级不可思议。当你看到这些艺术作品时，这太不可思议了。贾梅尔·沙巴兹与戈登·帕克斯配对。所以你看到了镜头的摄影方面
from the 40s and the 50s and 60s up to Jamel Shabazz starting in the 80s. And it just really shows the pass off of the inspiration. I'm the super, super dummy asshole who wished they understood it. Like I, yeah. But you know what, but Sean, we talked about this this summer,
从40年代、50年代和60年代一直到贾梅尔·沙巴兹从80年代开始。它真正展示了灵感的传递。我是那个超级、超级笨蛋混蛋，希望他们能理解它。就像我，是的。但你知道吗，但肖恩，我们今年夏天谈过这个，
which is I'm so new to it. I realized about five, no, I've always known this, but I said to somebody, I met a bunch of artists this summer and I kept saying, I have this crazy blind spot in my life, which is I've never appreciated art in a way, or I never understood it, I never spent the time, and I feel like.
那就是我对它太陌生了。我意识到大约五，不，我一直知道这一点，但我对某人说，我今年夏天遇到了一群艺术家，我一直在说，我的生活中有一个疯狂的盲点，那就是我从来没有以某种方式欣赏艺术，或者我从来没有理解它，我从来没有花时间，我觉得。
You're like, we don't go to museums. I felt really delinquent, or galleries, or go to shows. Because I'll go to a museum and there'll be a canvas, a painting, that is from the floor to the ceiling that is mass, that takes up the whole wall, and it's just painted one color, it's just painted black, or it's just painted red, or whatever it is. And I'll go, I could've done that, that's dumb.
你就像，我们不去博物馆。我觉得自己真的很失职，或者画廊，或者去看展览。因为我会去博物馆，那里会有一块画布，一幅画，从地板到天花板，那是巨大的，占据了整面墙，它只是涂成一种颜色，它只是涂成黑色，或者它只是涂成红色，或者不管它是什么。我会说，我本可以做到，那很蠢。
And then somebody will go, no, that's brilliant because, and then I'll go, oh wow, it's kind of fascinating. Yeah. Well, I went in, I met this, I met, and he was there the other night, I met, so this summer, I met and hung out a couple times, I went to his house, because he's a friend of a friend to Rashid Johnson's house, and he's got all this art in his,
然后有人会说，不，那很棒，因为，然后我会说，哦哇，这有点迷人。是的。好吧，我进去了，我遇到了这个，我遇到了，他那天晚上在那儿，我遇到了，所以今年夏天，我遇到了拉希德·约翰逊并和他一起玩了几次，我去了他家，因为他是朋友的朋友，拉希德·约翰逊的家，他家里有所有这些艺术品，
Rashid's got all this, and a bunch of his own art and I'm like Any and he was the guy and I said I go Rashid. I gotta be honest with you I don't know anything about art and he was and literally he was so kind and he goes I got you All right, and so we started talking and he started kind of like educating me I really want to learn actually one dude and what's really what I found is, you know, I started reading Biographies on artists and it gives you such a sense of who they are. And then when you do that, then you start to appreciate their process.
拉希德有所有这些，还有他自己的一堆艺术品，我就像，任何，他就是那个人，我说，我拉希德。我必须对你诚实，我对艺术一无所知，他就是，字面上他太好了，他说，我懂你。好吧，所以我们开始谈话，他开始有点像教育我，我真的很想学习，实际上一个家伙，我发现的是，你知道，我开始阅读艺术家的传记，它让你对他们是谁有了一种感觉。然后当你这样做时，你就开始欣赏他们的过程。
It's kind of like how you found soccer, right? Well, like you start learning about kind of the players and the whole sort of drama behind the team. Yeah, just like anything. That's exactly how I got into it. Yeah, and when I discovered the blend of Rice Krispies and marshmallows, I was like, this is incredible.
这有点像你发现足球的方式，对吧？好吧，就像你开始了解球员和球队背后的整个戏剧。是的，就像任何事情一样。这就是我进入它的方式。是的，当我发现米花糖和棉花糖的混合物时，我想，这太不可思议了。
Oh, you are the one eating the marshmallows and the Rice Krispie treats. I was trying to figure out who. Oh, listen. Because I couldn't believe it. He's a test kitchen for the Kraft Food Corporation. Yeah. He does it while we record.
哦，你就是那个吃棉花糖和米花糖的人。我一直在试图弄清楚是谁。哦，听着。因为我不敢相信。他是卡夫食品公司的测试厨房。是的。他在我们录音时做。
Let me ask you a super dumb practical question. You say all these pieces of art, these works are large scale. How do you, you live in New York City. You can't have the wall space to house all these things. Where do a lot of them live? Or do they just kind of, do you lend them to museums? Are they always on tour? Like how do you go about buying large pieces?
让我问你一个超级愚蠢的实际问题。你说所有这些艺术品，这些作品都是大型的。你怎么，你住在纽约市。你不可能有墙面空间来容纳所有这些东西。它们中的很多住在哪里？还是它们只是有点，你把它们借给博物馆？它们一直在巡演吗？你如何购买大型作品？
Well, this is the first time that the exhibition, this particular version of our collection, because this maybe represents about 30% of the collection, so this particular part of the collection is touring for the first time, and it is actually the first touring exhibition of color ever in any of these museums of a private collection. So this is really a very, very important and special thing.
好吧，这是展览，我们收藏的这个特定版本，第一次，因为这可能代表了收藏的30%左右，所以收藏的这个特定部分是第一次巡演，它实际上是任何这些博物馆中私人收藏的第一次色彩巡演展览。所以这确实是一件非常、非常重要和特别的事情。
And one of the things we did realize is not only is it really giving so much exposure to so many brilliant, brilliant artists, Ebony G. Patterson, Mickalene Thomas, Titus Kaffar. I mean, when you see this exhibition, you do have to see it, it is stunning. There's also a book that goes along with it, The Giant's book is spectacular.
我们意识到的一件事是，它不仅真正给了这么多才华横溢、才华横溢的艺术家如此多的曝光，埃博尼·G·帕特森，米卡琳·托马斯，泰特斯·卡法尔。我的意思是，当你看到这个展览时，你确实必须看到它，它太令人惊叹了。还有一本书随之而来，“巨人”书很壮观。
But otherwise it would be in storage. And as much as, you know, it has to be kept safe and stored properly, but how beautiful it is that people from all walks of life can go see this art and to your point, feel actually connected to it, not just like they're seeing something that they don't really connect to. And you see these works, you see things in your life,
但否则它会被存放在仓库里。尽管，你知道，它必须被安全地保存和妥善储存，但人们从各行各业都能去看到这些艺术是多么美丽，正如你所说，感觉实际上与它有联系，不仅仅是像他们看到了一些他们并不真正联系的东西。你看到这些作品，你在生活中看到事物，
you're emotional, it really brings you to beautiful spaces and for everybody, not just certain blocks of life or certain people, to be exposed is really the point. Yeah, and it's so generous of you guys to do that, to let the public see, because these are all one-offs. It's like someone coming over to your house or something. Yeah, exactly.
你很情绪化，它真的把你带到了美丽的空地，对每个人，不仅仅是生活的某些街区或某些人，被暴露才是重点。是的，你们这样做太慷慨了，让公众看到，因为这些都是一次性的。就像有人来你家或什么东西。是的，完全正确。
It is like that, actually. So for you to, otherwise people would have no chance to see all this stuff if you did have all the wall space, you know, some big, huge, the fact that you're touring it is philanthropic in and of itself. So that's very, very cool of you guys. It's a public service. I'm just looking it up.
它确实是那样，实际上。所以对你来说，否则如果你们确实有所有的墙面空间，人们将没有机会看到所有这些东西，你知道，一些大的，巨大的，你们正在巡演它的事实本身就是慈善的。所以这对你们来说非常、非常酷。这是一种公共服务。我只是在查它。
It's so cool. So it's right now at Atlanta's High Museum, right? Yeah. It is. Yeah, and then it was at the Brooklyn Museum. That's so cool. I want to go back to one question because I just want to know, do you still get nervous?
太酷了。所以它现在在亚特兰大的高等艺术博物馆，对吧？是的。它是。是的，然后它在布鲁克林博物馆。太酷了。我想回到一个问题，因为我只是想知道，你还会紧张吗？
I want to go to Atlanta and see it, sorry. I do too. Yeah, I have to. Do you still get nervous performing at all? Because before we were talking about adrenaline versus nerves, so do you get like, before you perform, do you get at all nervous anymore? You're just like, no, I got this, I've done this,
我想去亚特兰大看看它，抱歉。我也想。是的，我必须。你还会紧张表演吗？因为之前我们在谈论肾上腺素与神经，所以你还会紧张吗，在你表演之前，你还会紧张吗？你只是，不，我得到了这个，我做过这个，
I know this, it's in me. It kind of depends, you know, it's like, when I've been on tour for six months, I'm good. I'm like, okay, I know what I'm doing, I'm going to go out there and I'm a blah blah blah. At the beginning, I think of everything. There is such a beautiful feeling of like, do I have this? Is this going to go right? Scary, isn't it?
我知道这个，它在我心里。这有点取决于，你知道，就像，当我巡演了六个月时，我很好。我就像，好吧，我知道我在做什么，我要去那里，我是一个blah blah blah。一开始，我想一切。有一种如此美丽的感觉，就像，我有这个吗？这会顺利吗？可怕，不是吗？
Are they going to get me? It's a necessary fuel, yeah. Yeah, but I think it's really cool because you do get a chance to kind of like, you just give it a shot. So I definitely can feel nerves when I'm crafting something new. Or even just, I'll start creating new music soon. And even that, I'm like, how do I want to start that?
他们会抓住我吗？这是一种必要的燃料，是的。是的，但我认为这真的很酷，因为你确实有机会有点像，你只是试一试。所以我绝对可以在我制作新东西时感到紧张。或者甚至只是，我很快就会开始创作新音乐。即使那样，我也想，我该如何开始？
How do I want to create the space for that? What does it want to feel like? So I even think about like, what do I want to do? And there's this beautiful book called The Sage Warrior by a woman named Valerie Carr, who's this incredible, she's a lawyer, she's an activist, she's a woman who just, she's a writer, she does all this incredible stuff.
我该如何为它创造空间？它想感觉像什么？所以我甚至考虑，我想做什么？有一本美丽的书叫《圣人战士》，作者是一位叫瓦莱丽·卡尔的女性，她是一位不可思议的，她是一位律师，她是一位活动家，她是一位女性，她只是，她是一位作家，她做了所有这些不可思议的事情。
And she paired this book with this album of music that represents the theme of the book. And I said, you know, when I start to create, I just want to sit in a room and I want to read the book and hear the music and I want to like, what does that make me feel? And so just creating space for like, how do you create or what do you want to bring
她把这本书和这张代表书的主题的音乐专辑配对。我说，你知道，当我开始创作时，我只想坐在房间里，我想读这本书，听音乐，我想，那让我感觉如何？所以只是为像，你如何创造或你想带出什么
out of yourself? It's scary. But just to allow the space for you to do it is the first step. So yes, do I even get nervous? So to your point, I even get nervous kind of writing songs, writing new songs. Or performing for the first time.
你自己？这很可怕。但只是允许你这样做的空间是第一步。所以是的，我甚至会紧张吗？所以正如你所说，我甚至在写歌、写新歌时也会紧张。或者第一次表演。
Or a lot of times when it's just me, if I'm doing a piano show only, I feel the most nervous, because I'm like, man, I don't have anything to cover up or hide behind. There's no safe nets, yeah, yeah. Right, like this is it. But I've learned that it's also okay to just make mistakes and like you're human.
或者很多时候当我独自一人时，如果我只做钢琴表演，我会感到最紧张，因为我觉得，天哪，我没有任何东西可以掩盖或躲藏。没有安全网，是的，是的。没错，就是这样。但我已经学会了，犯错也没关系，因为你也是人。
Yes, I know. And that's the thing that got me out of being a classical music pianist, like to perform live. Because I did it for like 15 years or 20 years. And every single time I would go out to compete in competitions or whatever, it was so, I just wanted to shit my pants every single time.
是的，我知道。正是这一点让我不再做古典钢琴家，不再进行现场表演。因为我做了大约15年或20年。每次我去参加比赛或其他什么活动时，我都非常紧张，每次都想吓得屁滚尿流。
I'm like, what's the joy? And because if you're playing Beethoven or Chopin or Mozart or whoever it is, the notes are the notes. Like those are the notes. And if you miss them, everybody hears it. At least the people judging you hear it, right? And so you can miss it and go on, but it breaks you down the second you start
我在想，乐趣在哪里？因为如果你在演奏贝多芬、肖邦、莫扎特或其他任何人的作品，音符就是音符。那些就是音符。如果你弹错了，每个人都能听出来。至少评委们能听出来，对吧？所以你可以弹错然后继续，但一旦你开始
missing a passage. And I was performing in college once with this Mozart concerto and the orchestra behind me. And I blanked for half a page. I stopped playing and the orchestra behind me. And I blanked on like for half a page. I stopped playing and the orchestra kept going. I was like, oh my God, I'm sweating. I'm like, how am I, it's just me on stage. With 2,000 people.
漏掉一段，你就会崩溃。有一次我在大学里演奏莫扎特的协奏曲，后面有管弦乐队伴奏。我有一半的乐谱一片空白。我停止了演奏，而管弦乐队在后面。我有一半的乐谱一片空白。我停止了演奏，而管弦乐队继续演奏。我在想，天哪，我在冒汗。我在想，我该怎么办，舞台上只有我一个人。面对2000人。
And I'm like, and then you finally, I don't know how I got back in, but you just get back in. I'm like, you know what, I'm out. I'm not doing this. This is not a career. No, it's psychologically, really. And then you won a Tony for playing Gershwin all by yourself on stage.
我在想，然后你终于，我不知道我是怎么接回去的，但你就是接回去了。我在想，你知道吗，我不干了。我不做这个了。这不是一份职业。不，从心理上讲，确实如此。然后你凭借独自在舞台上演奏格什温的作品赢得了托尼奖。
Which was a challenge that I wanted to overcome, Jay. That's such a great point. Because I was like, if I'm ever going to live my life and get over this incredible nerves I have about performing the piano in front of people, I just have to tackle it. Yeah, go right through it. Did you play on stage?
那是我想要克服的一个挑战，杰伊。说得太好了。因为我在想，如果我这辈子还要继续生活，并且克服我在人们面前弹钢琴时那种难以置信的紧张感，我就必须去面对它。是的，直接面对它。你在舞台上演奏了吗？
Did you play? Oh yeah. Every night. Yeah, go right through it. Did you play on stage? Did you play? Every night. All by himself with a big grand piano. Rhapsody in Blue, start to finish. Rhapsody in Blue, start to finish? To end the show. It was incredible. It was very moving.
你演奏了吗？哦，是的。每天晚上。是的，直接面对它。你在舞台上演奏了吗？你演奏了吗？每天晚上。独自一人，用一架大钢琴。从头到尾演奏《蓝色狂想曲》。从头到尾演奏《蓝色狂想曲》？作为演出的结尾。太不可思议了。非常感人。
That's very nice. Not why I told the story, but thank you. No, it does seem like we've backed into it though a little bit. Pretty good, Sean. Go ahead, Sean. I was going to say, Elisa, all three of us have either lived or stayed in different parts of New York City. Is there a favorite of yours? A favorite part? Yeah, because we all kind of...
那很好。这不是我讲这个故事的原因，但谢谢你。不，这看起来确实像是我们有点绕回来了。挺好的，肖恩。继续吧，肖恩。我想说的是，艾丽西亚，我们三个人要么在纽约市的不同地方住过，要么待过。你有最喜欢的地方吗？最喜欢的部分？是的，因为我们都……
We all just got back from there yesterday. We came back together. Oh, amazing. Was it yesterday? I mean, somewhere between Harlem and Hell's Kitchen is definitely my sweet spot. On the West Side. Yep, I feel like I've always been a West Side girl.
我们昨天刚从那里回来。我们是一起回来的。哦，太棒了。是昨天吗？我的意思是，哈莱姆区和地狱厨房之间的某个地方绝对是我的心头好。在西区。是的，我觉得我一直是个西区女孩。
I really like it there. It has the energy. Obviously Hell's Kitchen is where I was raised and then Harlem I did a lot of growing up in my teenage years and there was, and then Harlem, I did a lot of growing up in my teenage years, and there was, and obviously, Harlem was also a different place then. It was just so unique, and the culture was just so clearly its own universe, and so there was so much that I received
我真的很喜欢那里。它有那种活力。显然地狱厨房是我长大的地方，然后哈莱姆区是我青少年时期成长了很多的地方，而且，然后哈莱姆区，我青少年时期成长了很多，而且，显然，那时的哈莱姆区也是一个不同的地方。它太独特了，文化显然是一个独立的宇宙，所以我从
from being able to be exposed to that. So I'd say somewhere between Harlem and Hell's Kitchen, even now, I spend a lot of time uptown, and I just really like it. So I'm kind of uptown west somewhere in that universe, midtown Harlem and Hell's Kitchen, that's my vibe. Yeah. Nice, yeah, I'm a Westside kitchen.
接触到这些经历中收获了很多。所以我说在哈莱姆区和地狱厨房之间的某个地方，即使是现在，我也花很多时间在上城，我真的很喜欢那里。所以我算是上城西区那个宇宙里的，中城哈莱姆和地狱厨房，这就是我的氛围。是的。不错，是的，我是西区厨房的。
Well, we're going to let you get back into that incredible city and your life. And you're just an absolute delight. I'm so, so happy that you got this. It's so cool to me. I could listen to you, Todd. You're so unbelievably in touch with yourself and you're able to articulate so well
好吧，我们要让你回到那个不可思议的城市和你的生活中去了。你绝对是一个令人愉快的人。我非常非常高兴你能来。这对我来说太酷了。我可以一直听你说话，托德。你对自己有着难以置信的了解，而且你能够表达得如此好
your connection with yourself. Yeah, it's unbelievable. Honestly, it's so cool. Thank you, guys. I'm really glad to be able to be a part of your crew today. Yeah. Thank you for having me. We're so lucky.
你与自己的联系。是的，这太不可思议了。老实说，太酷了。谢谢你们，伙计们。我真的很高兴今天能成为你们团队的一员。是的。谢谢你们邀请我。我们太幸运了。
And I'm so excited just to be with you guys. This is awesome. Thanks, likewise, likewise. Thanks for doing it and keep putting out all this incredible stuff. I can't wait to see what you do next. Yes, and I'll look you up on the West Side. Yes.
我很高兴能和你们在一起。这太棒了。谢谢，同样，同样。谢谢你们所做的一切，继续发布这些不可思议的内容。我迫不及待想看你们接下来要做什么。是的，我会去西区找你的。是的。
Yes. Thank you guys. Thanks, Alicia. Enjoy the rest of your day. Thanks, Alicia. Bye, sweetie. Thank you guys. Thanks Alicia. Enjoy the rest of your day. All right, bye sweetie. Thank you. Bye, bye. She's just like,
是的。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢，艾丽西亚。祝你余下的一天愉快。谢谢，艾丽西亚。再见，亲爱的。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢艾丽西亚。祝你余下的一天愉快。好的，再见，亲爱的。谢谢。再见，再见。她就像，
Yeah, she's like. Listener, I wish you could have seen the sunshine on her face. She had a grin on her face the whole time. Yeah. She's just such a good. Like that's somebody who's like, this is what I'm going to do,
是的，她就像。听众朋友，我真希望你能看到她脸上的阳光。她全程都笑得很开心。是的。她真是太好了。就像那种人，这就是我要做的事，
this is fulfilling to me, and I'm not going to stop stop the rest of my life. And the way she's able to deliver how she's feeling and talk about her experience, her past experience, where she's at now, like the facility that she has. The facility? The facility. That I obviously don't have.
这对我来说很有成就感，我余生都不会停止。她表达自己感受的方式，谈论她的经历、过去的经历、她现在的处境，那种能力。能力？能力。我显然没有的能力。
It's pretty, I found it remarkable. Do you find me as eloquent? Yeah, well, boy, I'm losing you. Are you going through a canyon right now? I try not to find you. Put it that way. How about that? You know what, there is one song that I love by hers,
这非常，我觉得很了不起。你觉得我口才好吗？是的，好吧，伙计，我听不清你了。你现在是在峡谷里吗？我尽量不去评价你。这么说吧。怎么样？你知道吗，有一首歌我很喜欢，是她的，
but we're gonna get to it later, it's called Goodbye. She actually wrote a song called Goodbye, but before I say that, I do. Are you gonna save that for your bye? Yeah. Oh, sorry, you putting a stake in your buy. Thanks for previewing that for us, we're ready. What are you doing?
但我们稍后再谈，它叫《再见》。她确实写了一首叫《再见》的歌，但在我这么说之前，我确实。你要把它留到你的再见环节吗？是的。哦，抱歉，你给你的再见埋下了伏笔。谢谢你为我们预告，我们准备好了。你在干什么？
You're a disaster. You're crashing from that Rice Krispie treat now. I am. It sure is. Wait, can you hear it if I play it on here or no? No, probably not, then we'll have to pay for it. What's your question, caller? Yeah.
你真是个灾难。你现在因为那块米饼而崩溃了。我是。确实是。等等，如果我在这里播放，你能听到吗？不，可能不行，那我们得付钱。你的问题是什么，来电者？是的。
My question was, well, first of all, oh, the art thing, like, I wish I'd give anything to be. In Atlanta right now, to see that show? Yeah, well that, yeah, and also just to like, learn about art, I just don't. Well, you don't have to, you don't have to be, and there are a ton of, as she was saying that her husband is good at identifying emerging artists,
我的问题是，好吧，首先，哦，艺术那件事，就像，我愿意付出任何代价去。现在在亚特兰大，去看那个展览？是的，好吧，那个，是的，还有就是去学习艺术，我只是不。好吧，你不必，你不必，而且有很多，正如她所说，她的丈夫擅长发掘新兴艺术家，
there are, as you can imagine, every day, tons of great young artists that you can go and you can kind of, and what you do is you, I know people who know about it, so I start asking them questions, and you just go, I'm gonna ask you the dumbest question. Who do you like? Shit like that.
有，你可以想象，每天都有很多很棒的年轻艺术家，你可以去，你可以某种程度上，你所做的就是，我知道有人了解这些，所以我开始问他们问题，然后你就去，我要问你一个最愚蠢的问题。你喜欢谁？诸如此类的事情。
And where are they? Help me understand what's good. But why, but you don't even, but not even what's good, because the good is different for everybody. You know what I mean? Just who do you like? And then you start identifying with other people and you have to be the ultimate arbiter of what's good.
他们在哪里？帮我理解什么是好的。但是为什么，你甚至不需要，甚至不是什么是好的，因为好对每个人来说都是不同的。你知道我的意思吗？只是你喜欢谁？然后你开始认同其他人，你必须成为什么是好的最终仲裁者。
Developing your taste. Yeah, yeah, because you can't rely on other people's opinion on art. I mean, that sure drives the commerce of it. But I think what we're all saying too is that like you said earlier, we are missing that in our lives. Like that's an entire modular, you know,
培养你的品味。是的，是的，因为你不能依赖别人对艺术的看法。我的意思是，这确实推动了它的商业化。但我认为我们都在说的是，就像你刚才说的，我们的生活中缺少这一点。就像那是一个完整的模块，你知道，
there's a section of life that we can easily go by and we have gone by up until now. Well, put it this way, I don't know about you guys, I would look at like a Jackson Pollock my entire life and I'd be like, do that thing which, you know, heathens do like me, is go, I could do that, I could just drop some fucking paint splat on the thing. And then you start reading about his life.
有一部分生活我们可以轻易地度过，而且直到现在我们确实也是这样度过的。好吧，这么说吧，我不知道你们怎么样，我这辈子看着像杰克逊·波洛克的东西，我会想，做那个东西，你知道，像我这样的异教徒会做的事，就是说，我能做到，我只要在上面滴几滴该死的油漆就行了。然后你开始读他的生平。
And then you start reading about where he was when he was doing those particular paintings and what was going on. And you have a different appreciation for what he did. And when you start to factor that in, it changes the way you look at it and appreciate it. Yeah, totally. Did you see this yesterday?
然后你开始读他在创作那些特定画作时身处何地，以及当时发生了什么。你对他所做的事情有了不同的欣赏。当你开始把这些因素考虑进去时，它改变了你看待和欣赏它的方式。是的，完全正确。你昨天看到这个了吗？
This story came out yesterday where this kid, this guy found a Picasso painting in a basement somewhere. And this is years and years and years and years and years ago, and the mom didn't know it was a Picasso, brought it over to the kitchen sink, used just soap and water to clean it off, and then hung it up on their wall. Look, it's in the background there.
这个故事昨天出来了，有个孩子，这家伙在某个地下室里发现了一幅毕加索的画。这是很多很多很多年前的事了，妈妈不知道那是毕加索，把它拿到厨房水槽里，只用了肥皂和水把它洗干净，然后挂在墙上。看，就在背景里。
You see it in the background? No way. Yeah. Their house, and they didn't know it was a Picasso. She's like, well, I'll just put this painting up. And they just found out this week that it's a real Picasso. This week? Yes, the whole fucking time. Because it's in the fucking time their family was. Because it's in the background of their family photos.
你看到背景里的了吗？不会吧。是的。他们的房子，他们不知道那是毕加索。她说，好吧，我就把这幅画挂上去。他们这周才发现那是一幅真正的毕加索。这周？是的，一直都是。因为它是他们家庭照片的背景。
No, no, yeah, and then they did the, the people looked at it, it's not wild. Well, there's all sorts of stories. There was the guy in, there was that guy who lived in Munich and he was kept taking the train to Switzerland and they're like, what's up with this dude? And then he had a bunch of dough on him.
不，不，是的，然后他们做了，人们看了它，这不疯狂吗？好吧，各种各样的故事都有。有个家伙在慕尼黑，他一直坐火车去瑞士，他们想，这家伙怎么回事？然后他身上带了一大笔钱。
They go back to his apartment and they bust through the wall and they realize he's got billions of dollars worth of art behind drywall in this apartment. It's like- Stolen from World War II? Probably, you know, a bunch of it unaccounted for, but quite literally billions of dollars worth of art.
他们回到他的公寓，砸开墙壁，发现他在公寓的干墙后面藏了价值数十亿美元的艺术品。就像——二战时偷的？可能吧，你知道，很多都下落不明，但确实是价值数十亿美元的艺术品。
So there's all sorts of things about their world that's kind of dubious when you start to get into the commerce of it too. Like you go, like, where do you store their art? Do you know about the whole system of duty free sort of art storage that exists at airports in the world, a few different places? Yeah, so they have these big, huge,
所以关于他们的世界，当你开始进入商业领域时，有很多事情是相当可疑的。就像你问，你在哪里储存他们的艺术品？你知道世界上一些地方机场存在的免税艺术品存储系统吗？是的，所以他们有这些巨大的，
this is not made, warehouses that are like the utmost security and they stay there and because they're not technically in that particular country, they can store them there tax free. Is this art? Is this art?
这不是编的，仓库拥有最高级别的安全保障，它们留在那里，因为它们在技术上不属于那个特定的国家，所以他们可以在那里免税储存。这是艺术吗？这是艺术吗？
Oh, it is. Look at Sean and Scotty. Can I say this? And this is going to seem like a cheap joke, but when it looks like that, it's not art. It's fart. That is fart. Because it looks like you're both farting. What's your favorite Alicia Keys song?
哦，是的。看看肖恩和斯科蒂。我能说这个吗？这看起来像个廉价的笑话，但当它看起来像那样时，它不是艺术。是屁。那是屁。因为它看起来像你们两个在放屁。你最喜欢艾丽西亚·凯斯的哪首歌？
I'm not sure, Sean. All right, Sean, go. Hey, what's your favorite Alicia Keys song? I'm not sure, Sean. What's yours? Goodbye. Goodbye. Smart. Less. Smart.
我不确定，肖恩。好吧，肖恩，开始吧。嘿，你最喜欢艾丽西亚·凯斯的哪首歌？我不确定，肖恩。你呢？《再见》。《再见》。聪明。少。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarff. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。SmartLess是由贝内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿姆贾夫100%有机且手工制作的。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。